ah
[Music]
my granddad gave me two bits of advice
when i was a young lad
brian there are two kinds of people in
this world there are beers
and doers don't be a beer be someone who
does
before i would go in the water it would
just be like check
check check check check check check
check you got good like everything was
just done
because it was life and death so when i
come into this industry
and like there's little tiny mistakes i
was just like flying off the [__]
handle
i just think i'm becoming more aware of
other people's feelings as i get older
sometimes that can be quite a painful
thing when you grow as a person and you
look back at what you used to be
sometimes you hate it
i had a bit of a moment a few months ago
where i just sort of had a bit of a
meltdown
it was unbelievable how often and how
bad the anxiety was and how bad the low
moods were
i couldn't shake it like it was just
like i do not want to be here
you know it got to a point where every
single day i was having suicidal
thoughts and like
it was sometimes multiple times a day
and it would just be like when things
were getting too much it was like
it's okay because if it gets too much
you can just end your life
and then one day i remember waking up
and i just had like a whole night of
nightmares and i was like
if i don't do something about this i am
literally going to end up dead
the sad thing is is in in that time my
dad's also been going through a really
bad time
my dad attempted suicide
and luckily i rang an ambulance
immediately
and the ambulance got to him and they
managed to
look after him and save him basically
[Music]
welcome back to the trujodi podcast
sponsored by
jim shark shout out to the boys at
gymshark and the girls uh
they look after us they really do they
send me stuff all the time by the way
really
yeah you can just ask them for it
they're just appears can i have their
numbers
it's joe isn't it the hookshot shoulder
yeah shout out to joey this show really
does look like we love
we love all of them joe tries so hard
and yet you're so
unloving when i hear you speak to him i
feel like you need to show joe
you have a love-hate relationship well
yeah in that he hates you and you're
supposed to love him
where's francis in ghana right either
get me the [__] interview
or it's over i'm on the plane to nigeria
joe you told me he'd be here
um but yeah uh shout out to jim shot
they just signed
the ufc heavyweight champ of the world
and they signed them before the fight
actually they put their money where
their mouth is
right million gym shots we do the same
thing it's amazing
it's a really smart thing um so yeah
shout out to them giving a lot of love
out of them you got the links in the
description for everything you need
if you want to look good when you're in
the when you're working out now that we
can go back to the gym
thung [__] how do you feel now you're
getting back in the gym i mean i was
sort of training but not the same way
now now i'm it's full of steam ahead now
also has your training changed a bit
because your body the body you want to
achieve
is now not the same body you had before
before you wanted to be bigger right you
wanted to be like
no just a man mountain that was sort of
forced upon me
lawrence by what by mcdonald's all right
okay well yeah on
genetics genetics and mcdonald's
genetically
i don't know i think that most people
are predisposed to put on weight when
they mcdonald's
it's not like a you thing do you know
what i mean like i just i don't want to
favor mcdonald's because burger king
also okay
you eat just as much of that do you love
a double whopper yeah
and what about the burgers uh that'll be
clipped up what about kfc that'll go
into a future life story of mine
now i've seen this is very popular on um
i've seen them very popular on other
youtube channels
what's your favorite fast food
restaurant no we're not doing that brand
you value being anonymous online
absolutely lawrence do you value being
able to surf the web
anywhere in the world yeah yeah yeah
that's why you'd love surf shark there
are sponsors on the podcast today
brilliant
really great sponsors these guys offer
all sorts of services
through one simple application and
browser extension
yeah so i can get it on my phone but i
can also get it on my laptop but i could
also put it on my second laptop
or you know my other little tablet-y
thing that i just sort of carry around
from time to time
anywhere that's the point and all for
one fee as well but say that you're
bored of netflix in the uk because
you're only just coming out locked down
now and you've seen a lot of the netflix
i've seen everything yeah
you can go to another country's netflix
and farm the [__] out of that netflix
i want to be able to see americans i
want to be able to see italians i want
to be able to see the spanish not only
that but say they want to protect your
identity online or you know you go on
wi-fi
in a coffee shop or something you want
to protect the outgoing signal
no worries you're welcome click the link
in the description use code
geordi at checkout and you get 83 off
and
three months extra for free so that
means you're only
paying for 17 of the price genuinely
that's unbelievable
when i first read that i was like sorry
did you put 83 there i thought you meant
maybe 38 or something no
83 was correct we emailed surf shark and
went there's got to be something wrong
here they went
no no problems genuinely it's as good as
so head over to the website look at the
deal
and if you go through our link in the
description below they'll know that
yeah it makes us look good and it keeps
you in podcasts
sorry what the hell does that mean and
it keeps you
in pocket you're welcome what are we
doing here
uh what's been going on people just
wanted us to do a catch-up obviously we
did the the next episode video
we did that that took way too long
please get off you took them down when
they really laid
crying yeah are you happy for us yes
we're making money yes
yeah exactly why are you crying because
we're making we could have just done it
like that in three words
yeah i get the thing that doesn't emote
the same response
yeah but you know would have been less
work for you so yeah i know but i
buttered it yeah ultimately was it worth
the the squeeze
yeah the juice was worth the squeaky it
was so many people messaged me saying
they were crying
you know what it brought back so many
memories for me it wrecked me mentally
because i watched
every podcast front to back with the guy
filming this right
well he was already mentally ruined
anyway but you know it must have sent
him deeper down the hole
because when you watch yourself back
from the last five
imagine now anyone who doesn't record
themselves on a regular basis
that you're just sitting in your office
and every moment when you've made a joke
every time you've put yourself out there
every time that you've had a cooler
a you know water cooler moment or you've
made coffee and made a joke to one of
your
friends in the office or wherever you
work that's recorded and then played
back to you
five years later and people in the
comments are going that's not very good
or people go we don't like this guy or
people are commenting like he's wrong or
you were just
wrong it mentally it was a trip
it was it was great for me to watch and
yeah there's and luckily i wasn't the
one editing it
[__] for that yeah and there is always
that would have taken even longer but
obviously the story sort of focused
around me
you didn't actually when i look back at
you put in enough of your good moments
but there were there were little bits
like you know us laughing at um
email and stuff like that but yeah but
it was your story as well no but i i
appreciate
that and it's it's it's it's an honor to
have your best me
right sort of tell your story for you
because also we've seen it
closest well yeah you know yeah more
than anyone yeah exactly
unfortunately yeah exactly because now
the only only option is for you to kill
me i'll bribe you
no definitely kill yeah i wouldn't
accept a bribe no that's the thing
you're not actually driven by money so
now you're in that
yeah and i'll pay you off although i did
buy my i gotta admit i did this thing
yesterday where i took my son to
hamley's
you ever been to a really good toy shop
before
not for a long time right i'll tell you
two things about good toy shops
um first of all incredibly fun second
full of adults that still believe that
they are children
like youtube then yes no no hamley's is
very much
the youtube of the high street right
because
first of all anyone can walk in there
initially when you walk in very much
like on youtube you go
this is good isn't it oh this is hey
look it's
recommending all the things i like like
bubbles and and police cars and all this
stuff
you get downstairs you get in the deep
dark bits the basement right you find
the [__] basement
you've wandered onto some dark [__] all
right
first of all it's just a there's a
massive bear just walking around
downstairs
my son freaked the [__] out when he saw
this bear
he didn't know what to react he didn't
know how to react until he looked at me
and went he's laughing
guess i laugh as well yeah initially he
went like he's
i've never seen him so shocked we're
walking around looking for a bubble
machine downstairs right i know this
probably isn't the story people came
here no people wanted to hear that right
i put it out
on the old social media and they were
like tell us about laurence's dad's
story right okay
walking down walking around where it's
quite dingy when you get downstairs in
hamley's like it's not
set up like a kid's toy store but if
it's harry potter so you're like oh
maybe it's a theme
you wander through the harry potter part
you get out the other side and you think
you found the bubble machines
i'm looking one way flu's looking the
other baby's just sitting there he's
having a great time
out of nowhere a tiny small fat man
appears with a harry potter wand
and i'm not joking i turn around from
looking over here and i think we oh
my god and there is a man with the wand
at
flu's temple and he what does he show
and he goes kazaar and that isn't even a
harry potter it's not even harry potter
thing right
and flu surely expect or patrol him flew
literally goes
ah like oh my god does she play along or
was she generally terrified i could say
you know if you know flee metfor she's
not the kind of person who plays along
instantly
definitely not she realized this man was
uh we we sort of worked out this man was
slightly mentally
challenged um but not fully worked there
was he just
worked there but we can work out if he
was if he was sort of
you know um on the spectrum in a sense
of you know there's somewhere where he
believes he is actually harry potter
whether he's worked in a kids store so
long
that he now just is stuck in this world
and he's plays with everyone that he
meets
i genuinely believe this man never left
the store like
he was dressed in a little jumper that
didn't fit him quite right
and he just kept following us around and
like would just pop up and sort of go
bubble machines is it that you like and
i go yep and he'd go
take a look at this one and you and i
was like that's weird isn't it it's just
strange
and then he came over with the bear and
was like have you met the bear do you
like the bear
and we were like the bear scared the
child anyway i could take the bear away
if that's
we were like yeah yeah take anyway he
led the bear away and as he led the bear
away
the bear mind being sad and i was like
this is a weird world
culvert's done weird things to the world
absolutely yeah
we're not talking about cover um so yeah
that it wasn't quite duncan's um
toy chest or whatever it was i thought
malone where the old man's nice that was
what i
ultimately the guy didn't see the turtle
doves i wanted i wanted
an old man to walk over and go what is
friendship
there you go go away my son so uh what
what you what you're learning from being
a dad so far then you're coming up the
one year
yeah um what have i learned about being
a dad um
you know what you really think about
when you first have a kid right legacy
you start thinking about what you're
leaving behind right okay and also the
way your own parents treated you
does that make sense you're getting some
childhood trauma coming out is it
no more like more like you know when
people see me in a picture in
40 50 years time not 40. i hopefully
i'll still be alive by now
um a hundred years time right wow
what will they think will they will they
watch the podcasting go
right no we well maybe with a free
frozen our brains or something
40 years time from now i'll be 70
luckily okay um
yeah i'm not planning on being around
then sure i'm i'm on the
like the fast lane here then the other
thing i thought which now
comes back to you will this podcast be
watched in 40 years time and people go
what a funny little time do you know
what i mean yeah is that
even genuinely thinking about this a lot
yeah yeah like a lot a lot you know
which is why i'm wondering how i cut my
hair and stuff now well i've not made a
decision
so you you're basing your haircut off
the style that may be
in 100 years this is this is what i'm
suggesting
will be called 100 years time beats
headphones but they'll be permanently on
the head
always yeah always and that's shaggy
yeah exactly yeah and you've done it the
other way so i love that i've gone the
other way yeah
i know what you mean like legacy you do
start thinking about that
but just also how you're perceived in
the world do you know what i mean
like that's that changes as you get
older and you re
you like you know when you're young
you're like [__] it okay there's not a
general opinion of one person though is
there
uh no but what i mean is like famous or
whether people in my family look at that
and go
do you remember him he was a bit he
wasn't you know
whether in 100 years time everyone would
be like christians and sort of go
he didn't live a very clean living life
did he you know what i mean
or whether we'll get cancelled because
of some of the definitely the
[__] with cats podcast get what you mean
yeah like you do start thinking what is
the purpose of all of this right
and things begin to feel a bit more
fixed
that's why i want it to be layered what
we're doing here right you know what i
mean
like yeah there's some stuff that is
just sort of here at the day gone
tomorrow like you know the kickoff
the football stuff what we're talking
about is irrelevant in a week's time
because some new [__] just happened
it matters so much in the moment but
yeah but it's fun and
you know it's that emotional tribalism
bollocks that we get tucked into but
glad you acknowledged that with uh the
podcast and some of the people we've
interviewed and i think that's what your
video showed
right is at times it does get very
meaningful at times
we are doing more than just a little
one-on-one chat
yeah and that's why you know having
people like elizabeth smart on
who've got more than just um you know
five minutes of fame but have got really
life lessons to hand over to people of
how dear how dealing with
hardship real desperately bad hardship
how you can go through that and come out
the other side and be a good person
these are the sort of things that i
think
i like to say well at least we've got
that because most youtubers
it is just the here today gone tomorrow
[__]
95 99 of youtubers will go through 10
years
and they'll barely make a single
meaningful video that actually touches
someone inside
so and there's nothing wrong with that
because i do think it's healthy to have
chewing gum you know content yeah yeah
you know you're just chewing through it
yeah yeah threw it in the bin that that
was all right
it lasted five minutes but for that five
minutes the taste was all right yeah
generally i'm not fresh
and a lot of our content has been that
way as well but
if i don't challenge myself and we don't
challenge ourselves to make something
meaningful along the way
that we actually have in the pile of
things we're proud of
you and i i think we'd both just be like
what are we doing you know i actually
realized
it physically impacts me if i don't feel
like happy with
work or like i don't feel like we're
making good videos like i actually look
different
and there's there's actual science to
back up that if you aren't happy
with what you're doing in your life your
face begins to look different
yeah like your face physically if you've
realized certain things about yourself
apparently your face will look as if
i must admit there was someone i i
remember from my younger years in life
who was a really bad person
and the older they got like they were
a fairly good-looking person in their
younger life but the older they got
the worse it showed on their face and
you end up looking like a camilla park a
bulls type
ugly woman like right do you ever wonder
though
like first of all vicious towards
camilla parker no but
i do think like bad people it does show
like on them
yeah i mean but i was wondering how much
i'm not saying camilla's bad but you
know well
probably is doesn't she you know what
she said to diana i really don't like
okay so um but ultimately what part of
me wondered how much of that is down to
my own self-perception
and how much i'm taking on other
people's perceptions and then that shows
in your face do you ever wonder
do you ever look at like especially when
i was looking at the podcast i looked at
how different our faces looked when we
started
to now i i change a lot i'm i'm yeah you
really do like
right at one point we're over and i were
having this discussion about whether we
could do another video
which was almost like a flick book of
like your face on the podcast
so weird and we are kind of still
thinking of doing that i think it would
be
it would be a bit of a trip for you it i
am quite
known for changing my appearance
depending on the photograph and when it
was taken
like there are some people who look the
exact same person
10 years old with me
it's [__] mental how much uh yeah
what one day you've got a beard the next
day
you've still got the beard i don't know
if this makes sense or not but i know
from taking pictures of myself i'm like
how the [__] are those two pictures to
me the same five minutes support this i
even know that
you know what i also notice um your own
self-confidence is different now as well
like yeah uh you you know
well you know you five years ago
you wouldn't have taken some of the self
shots that you've taken that you take
now maybe because you didn't feel the
same way about your body back then
uh-huh you didn't feel
i don't know what what look were you
going for five years ago
i know i started that sentence it didn't
sound mean but i finished it and it is
okay the god's honest truth though is
like
a wild [__] is what i was wasn't
it like you remember how wild i was but
then like
there's many stories that we just cannot
tell on the podcast
but the point is i did not give a [__]
like
anyone who challenged me was getting it
and like
i just didn't think about stuff the way
i do now like
meeting you was a very big turning point
where i was like oh
okay there are other ways to do this
like
life yeah i think you and i actually
both changed the uh saw the other one
and went oh there's other ways of doing
this
yeah but yeah we came at things from
completely different angles so then
meeting you yeah it completely changed
me
i always say this after my own mother
you are the person who's affected me
the more say my life do you know what i
had as a flashback to
some of the clothes i wear were terrible
i know that i mean
both of you and i have fashion
photographers i was just never going to
see
but the real the realistic thing was
though i would go to business meetings
and
when i look back at it i think wow like
you know what i mean
i would turn up to business meetings i
i'll never forget my worst one
i turned it when i when i turned up to
meet alan shearer i went to
it was it was not to meet shira but i
think that was the only reason i went
right was this khan festival thing for
advertising
and shira was there and everyone was a
nice smart
summer way and i literally bought a vest
in jeans with 45 on the floor
like that no it was it was like a green
camel look investment right that one
yeah i look back at it and like
especially how
out of shape i was as well yeah and it's
just like that you weren't in territory
no but it's the lack of [__] given that
it's quite mental
and it was like that for a long time and
i don't know i'm
i'm never going to be the guy who's
obsessed with the way he looks of course
and i'll never be the one getting his
top off in all the the pictures or
whatever else but um
i am taking more pride in my appearance
so it shows in the photos you take as
well and like it kind of it shows in
your face
as well and all these kind of things you
i think you can really
maybe it'll be interesting do this to
all youtubers like if you're a fan of a
youtuber
maybe go take a look at their face five
years ago in their face now
and work out what isn't just aging but
it's also like self-perception and
all these kind of things yeah if you
look at the big youtubers like i mean
take ksi and logan for example if you
look at them pre-fight and now
they they just have their men yeah it's
simple
disney nomics which is it's uh simba in
disney right
simba starts with a soft face ends with
this sculpted
like you can even see it and it's the
same with when you become a man
your face changes you become more
sculptured
the lion king that's great i bet you're
you're watching some of that now are you
he's just about transitioning into that
phase now where he looks he's
transitioning already
yeah exactly well i didn't want to say
him
but he is transitioning into being he's
in that phase now where he can
he's into narrative and not just into
like
yeah and he reacts to that kind of thing
everything the light touches
is our kingdom i had to i was 20 minutes
late today because i had to
i tried to leave and he wouldn't
go let go and that was the first time
he's ever done that today like he knew i
was leaving
as a as a person looking from the
outside in um
obviously the the supporters of the pod
want to know what it's like for you
being a dad
yeah but just i think you've dealt with
it fantastically
i thought it would be harder than this
so far and i'm not i'm not begging for
something hard to happen but what i mean
is like
i thought that just the id like it would
weigh much more mentally on me
the idea of this other person in my life
is what i mean i'm not saying i've found
it easy because it isn't
but i didn't think it was way much more
obvious
you are not a selfish person so i think
the fact that you are
a giving person by nature means that
someone like you
while you might feel tired and exhausted
and all the other things that any parent
feels
you're not built to be in shock when you
have to
put someone else before you and i think
especially men
that's the bit that men struggle with
because
we're not you know we're selfish
bastards let's be honest yes
and i obviously women um i do think
genetically or
um predisposed to go into this sort of
mother mode
when they do have a child so that it it
it doesn't shock them the way it can
for some women get shocked but like you
know i see what you're saying but i feel
like some men
like and we've heard rory for example on
the kickoff talk bloody hell
like when rory talks about being a dad
he's like so [__] bad
like but now he seems to absolutely love
it but it seems like the first year like
really
took him took him by surprise almost
it's really
changed uh our relationship as like
parents
in terms of you know flu and i okay
she's
uh we've just seen i've seen so many
other brilliant aspects of her that i
hadn't
really witnessed before i think like
maybe you just don't see in a person
can i cover up this by saying if your
relationship
is not working oh absolutely the
solution isn't
like lawrence and blue are getting on
fine just before this
relatively but do you know what i mean
though but like right some people view
some people let's get a dog like i i've
i've seen people where they're
struggling
and because out of fear of losing the
other person they just get pregnant
they're like right
we're gonna break up we need to do
something drastic to keep together pull
the pull the goalie
basically yeah right back of the net
right and
you know what sometimes it's just fun
hitting the back of the net isn't it
popping up the arsenal that's all i'm
saying
um that is another net insult definitely
um
yeah and that's actually really good
advice genuinely there are people out
there
oh oh like some people get a bit
squeamish with anal sex
i feel like it's become more mainstream
in the past few years since we started
the podcast
i genuinely think anything but related
has become
more mainstream butts are just great at
the one though
sure yeah yeah no i agree that's
actually true just yeah just are
yeah and the fact is it's gone full
circle because a few years ago if you'd
have
said that you would have been like
cancelled but now
we're all open-minded enough to know
that ass is important
there's there's yeah yeah there's a lot
of that going around
i mean people are getting injections in
the bottoms i'm not for it
i personally think that if the baby had
come out and looked completely different
to flu and i
and and she gone by the way this is none
of this
is real i'd have gone i feel lied to
oh all right you you want the real deal
well i just want to know what i'm
getting do you know what i mean
do you subscribe to the look at the
mother thing you know how men say look
at the mother of the misses that you're
with
oh yeah well if that's the case then flu
is not going to age from now until 60.
i've met
um flu's mum yeah yeah yeah she's a very
good looking woman
yeah yeah i'm just going to leave it at
that i've also noticed that dad's quite
attractive so either way
we're good i don't remember him i was
just looking at the mother i tell you
one of the best things that uh that has
happened to us is he's got blue eyes
i don't have blue eyes fluids in our
blue eyes apparently it can skip a
generation really my dad has blue eyes
and my grandmother had one oh that's
cute so he's got his amazing deep blue
eyes we don't show his face on social
media he's got amazing
deep blue eyes honestly but for those
who want to know what he looks like
just imagine lawrence but smaller and
shaven so not er no beard yeah if you
shaved me i probably would look like he
looks
he looks a lot like you and your dad the
amount of people who go
he's got something in his eye it seems
to be a bit puffy and i just go sorry
have you not
no genuinely flu regularly goes he must
have something in his eye it's really
puffy i'm like
this is normal can we can we address my
eye while we're talking about oh the
dodgy eyes that one
yeah what the yeah of your nose what's
that is that a what's that cause that
style i don't know
right i've had people give multiple
opinions on it long story short that
the consensus is i probably got a whack
at boxing
yeah you know you know how you're sweaty
and all that and two men are punching
each other
and it's probably a little bit of an
infection off of that like
conjunctivitis
i don't know it feels fine right i've
got to my jobs it hasn't done does it
is it painful i know it's all right but
i'm going to doctors uh next week i
think they're gonna have to take
something out or something i don't know
the eye scares me a bit do you know what
i mean like anything around the eye
the eye is so i know genuinely i i do
feel the same way but
what the [__] am i going to do i look
ridiculous right now it does honestly i
don't even notice it really
and we can light it so now i can't stop
looking at it i i feel sorry
for also because logan has a similar
problem he gets it every now and then
you're both boxes
logan had the exact same shape right
before he had to do wrestlemania so he
had to show up at wrestlemania
wearing those sunglasses that's why i
had the sunglasses i get it because
otherwise a wrestler definitely would
have picked up i think it must be a
boxing thing as well because he had it
right at the same time so what you're
basically doing is you're punching
someone and leaving
a whole load of germs and bacteria all
over the end of the glove
and then transferring it into the eye
basically yes
where you're then i remember when i had
a bit of a black eye from that week when
um vidal smacked me yeah yeah
like that yeah how's that going with um
you know boxing someone who's a
potential
wheelchair luckily i haven't had you for
a couple of weeks because um yeah he
took uh he was busy sparring some other
victim that week
okay you know what i mean but when i
when i asked for him i've got like a
body uh armor on as well oh i didn't
realize that okay
yeah so that is the one saving grace as
these body shots just tend to move me
across the ring rather than um
break my ribs tell me though what's it
like having someone so
you know you've done training and when
you're in the ring you felt quite safe
because you know derek
like derek's not a harmful guy when he's
training you he's just asking you to
punch pads
no you smash my face right remember that
but what's
but the point is when you've then got
vidal in there who's not training you
yeah he's actually out with intent no
what does that feel like like what
what do you remember what you felt like
the first time when derek went hopping
within videl
uh i sort of wasn't um
i think i think we we talked about this
a little bit on a clip before but
um i only sort of i trust these guys so
much that i only sort of really realized
what the [__] was going on about a
minute in
when i was like oh [__] this is getting
harder does your stomach react
what what's your like uh physical
reaction to anything
uh it's just survival mode really really
it's like
the last time i spoiled him i just
remember thinking
i want to quit i want to quit he's going
to drop me yeah he's going to really
[__] drop because he was just tagging
me
like and and when i spot other people
like yeah i get roughed up
yeah but when i when i spot vidal my jaw
hurts afterwards because he's so
accurate so like
he doesn't just punch you he punches you
in the perfect spot with the perfect
technique
everything's so perfect but afterwards i
remember having a burger afterwards and
like my jaw was actually
saw and like i was like like really
struggling
so you're finding out like little side
effects that you'd never think
it's just being in there with a pro and
versus being in there with like
the regular lads that we train with it's
like uh
going from you know playing around with
a [__] pussycat or a lion you know i
mean there's a huge
it's a huge difference and it just gave
me such an appreciation now for when i
watch fighters
who are getting the [__] beaten out of
them like in the ring of like
you know sometimes in the past i might
have said certain things and not really
respected what the loser was going
through or
you know what i mean like is that say
that you had actually been in real life
fights
yeah but so but but it's just the elite
level that these guys
spend the time in in the gym and all of
that so it
it made me regret some of the things
i've said in the past
about when you're apologizing well no
i've said it now but i you know i paid
for it you know what i mean yeah
it's like all right reality check do you
get used to it after a while where you
like you think you're on the way to a
session you're just like yeah just
completely normal i'm just going to get
in the room with it
or is it every time it's like i'm
getting in the ring with someone today
there's an element of nerves for me
every time just even if i know i should
be fine
i just think serious [__] you know what
i mean like but i'm getting better with
it
i'm getting more confident how do you
feel about your body now
uh better yeah yeah much better
like the whole thing i mean there's
still plenty of areas i'm thinking that
could be a bit
longer no yeah thicker yeah um
but you know it's like it ain't gonna
happen overnight it's more just me
feeling fitter that i'm happy with
right it's the performance side of it
that i'm preferring that comes with a
confidence as well doesn't it that gives
you confidence well yeah because in the
rebuild
uh you know people who watch the rebuild
you know every time i got in the ring
i was constantly under the awareness of
i'm gonna get tired before directors and
that is a terrifying thing
because you know the minute you get
tired it doesn't matter how hard i've
been hit
he can then pour on the the the pressure
and i'm i'm [__] then so now i'm
getting in the ring with people
and i'm able to put them under pressure
and i'm strong
then it's a different completely
different feeling now
and and i'm getting better at boxing i
think people are going to see some when
we finally do rebuild three i think
people are going to be like oh right
he's actually good how do you um control
your self-confidence now because
it's fair to say if you're getting all
this praise and you're thinking you're
really good at boxing
i could skyrocket in what way well like
you know when you first started boxing
you you were quite confident but derek
definitely brought you back down to
earth
at one point you're now building it back
up
but there's sort of like there's a
plateau that you're going to reach at
some point and
i'm just interested to see what the next
level is like how how
far you can actually take this yeah your
level and your ability can be
my self-confidence will never get out of
control because when you've got people
like derek and vidal around you
that's why vidal's so chill because
his dad will like literally doesn't
matter if he's world champion
his dad will still talk to him like
you're still
without me right you know what i mean so
and like at the minute i get in there
with either of those two it's a
different [__]
world all together so you know i can
beat up anyone
doesn't really matter because i know
that there's someone harder so it
doesn't
it's not like i'm going to start
thinking i'm [__] heavyweight trump
of the world all of a sudden can feel
that way that can't it
well yeah in that little moment where
you have your wing or whatever you beat
someone up or you do better
it feels great but i'm never like i
never walk out with her and be like
yeah i'm the [__] man i never do that
i just wouldn't
you know what i mean no i get it it's
smart it's good to see the physical
confidence and difference in you though
mentally do you feel different i feel
lighter right like actually is in you
feel the lightness in your body
i literally feel like there's a spring
in my step because i'm not carrying
around all the way
like from when we started the rebuild i
was obviously 23 stone
i'm now like 20 and a half which is mad
like
three stone weight loss in almost for
anyone is an insane amount of weight
um that's like 20 that was yeah 20 of
your body weight
i don't know why it was about 40 pounds
or something yeah quite a lot for some
people they weigh that
yeah mental in it like you were walking
around you know if i hugged me
and then jogged that's what it would
have been like
for me i know that over time like you
know you build up tendons and muscles
and stuff
so it's naturally you're going to be
built different but it's mad to me that
if i'd have jumped on my own back
and then gone time to box that would
have been the weight that you boxed at
when you first yeah what were you
11 and a half right yeah so i was
literally yeah
two of that yeah like i don't and that's
what i don't think a lot of people
realize or think about is like
when they say i'm unfit and all of that
[__] yeah or just when anyone says
anything
like you know to lose for me to lose a
stone would look very different and
that's what yeah
that's what i'm realizing is for a big
lad i am
really fit yeah like i know i know
the the pace i can put on people now i'm
like okay
like when i'm sparring really fit lads
i'm like you're you're struggling as
well here
i you know this ain't about power like
if i wanted to put
real hard punches together i could but
it's about like i'm trying to get
fit i'm trying to get faster trying to
become better at the boxing side of
things does it impact your daily life
any different like are you um
is your decision making quicker or like
are you
you know can you now turn and get a
train quicker i [__] want to sleep
more that's for sure
do you sleep a lot no i'm i'm just
wrecked like that
like on on a workout now because i'm
sweating so much and i'm really
exhausted myself like
my normal workouts used to be wait left
wait left weightless
right we're going home like now i am
dripping with sweat when i leave a gym
and i'm putting
and i'm doing cardio every single time
do you do anything to recover
uh no i've i've heard ice baths so good
but i haven't done it yet cold showers
are good as well have you ever done a
cold shower my coughs and [__] are like
really tight [__] question have you
ever done a cold shower yeah but not by
choice just because these [__] didn't
[__] sort the
water out you should do a cold shower
every time you've done a session
yeah because genuinely it changes the
healing like i i cold shower after every
like
exercise i do it check like you don't
feel it the next day
or relatively less i can't recommend
cold showers enough
i want to live in a country where i can
come through the cold hot cold like i'd
love to live in sweden for a little
while and like
do those ice plunge things that i think
we should go to sweden
i mean i know why you want to go to
sweden but i think
we should go to sweden do you know what
i mean we should go to sweden do a sauna
and then jump in the snow together i'd
love to do that
wearing thongs no no wearing nothing now
i want
i want to see it all there'll be not
much to say bro but that's that's the
thing i remember
i remember once my suit flooded you told
me this is the story you actually told
but we cut it out in the end
yeah and i remember getting out and i
just remember looking at my dick
afterwards being like jesus christ
what's going on
wow where is it yeah it was so freezing
for that long length of time
but genuinely uh like think about how
far you've come like
there's a what i had to watch was also a
lot of you
talking about your own self journey and
one thing you did say about diving is
you never felt like you had a creative
outlet while you were diving
but the funny thing was even though you
were diving you were always making
videos so you were still videoing and
probably pissing off about fifty percent
of the people in the same way
looking back at it all that little
footage i was taking the whole time and
like you've seen the little videos i
made yeah
i mean one day we should probably post
them just i think you should just
publish them [__] it who cares
do you like a true geordie archive
channel yeah it was
uh i think it's hilarious sometimes you
can only connect the dots backwards in
life
and i think there's probably a lot of
people i was thinking about this the
other day because like we get messages
off
you know younger people all the time
saying you know how to what should i do
in life and it was like
you know my passion was staring as right
in the face the whole time
yeah and i just did not realize
that that could even be a career of any
sort right you know what i mean
and youtube was around then i just was
like oblivious really i was like
it always did it also not seem available
because no one on the platform looked
like you
yeah but also i had no idea that there
was money in this or anything like that
and even when i eventually did start i
didn't know there was money in it until
like a year down the road
or as much money as diving or as much
money as you could have made somewhere
else no
no clue me no clue i literally thought
if i make minimum wage doing youtube
i'd rather do that than be richer and
diving so i'll do that and be happy
has anyone from the diving world seen
any of your videos and sort of
been in contact or just anyone like your
previous life
yeah my diving instructor the guy who
coached us on the the first
um the whole first few months steve
um i don't know what his name is um was
it
no um but anyway uh he he sent an email
in and i knew it was him
and i was like wow and he was like well
done you're an inspiration and all of
that and i thought
you were a [__] to us really no but like
you know that that's what they like in
it military in it it's like
everyone just gets beasted when you're a
young little [__]
rat did you enjoy that to some extent
like did you enjoy the
the test i i there was moments where i
did yeah there were
looking back at the diving that my
happiest memories were like
i remember there was this thing where we
do the deepest air dives possible down
to like 50 meters
and sorry when you say air dyes what
does that mean sorry we're breathing air
um in order to go deeper you have to
breathe the different um
yeah like yeah a mix of uh oxygen and
helium so that and then you end up
having to stay down for a lot longer and
all of that but for anyone out there we
took about 15 minutes to get to this uh
diving thing but
go for it it is interesting but i just
it comes on every podcast isn't it sorry
um and i remember they basically say
like you have to go right down to the
bottom and do like surveys or whatever
but it was
it was the moment where i would go head
first
and there'd be a rope going right out
the bottom but like
i would literally fly down and it was
almost like
skydiving you know what i mean like if
you imagine but i'm underwater i just
say
but i but i was a rat scene in gta i was
a rapid swimmer so
when me and this whoever i was with i'd
[__] raced on me
and just that feeling of utter
fearlessness islam
i'm flying towards the seabed underwater
and i just remember thinking like
this is cool as [__] this did you enjoy
it like that was one of the moments i
did
there was there was some moments you
know but but
like long term the more i did it the
more i realized the same for me like you
know these aren't my kind of
kind of boys they're not like really
what what kind of boys
no there were some lads absolutely loved
but like generally speaking
i don't know there was a lot of unhappy
people there do you know what i mean
like
and and i don't mean that in a like you
know like
a judgmental way no like hard grafting
men who are like a lot of the time doing
it to support a family at home
and often haven't seen the family in
months on end
and i [__] respected them but that
changes a man doesn't it well
yeah yeah there was like i just remember
this one guy who like he was putting his
daughter through uni
and my nickname from the godfather and
he was like this hard-nosed scottish guy
proper diamond of a block but like he
was like yeah
i ain't been home for however many
months but i just don't want her to have
any debt from university and that and
that was the site
and the guy was just working and working
like just like strike while the iron's
hot and like i appreciate that and as a
young lad like i was in and
uh i think on one of that job i was
earning about 9 000 pounds a month
that's good and you know it was 12 hour
days every [__] day if not
more and i really i felt like a part of
the team and the thing i was always
really good at was like
ingratiating myself with the boys and
making everyone laughing like
i was the life and soul of the party
sort of thing and i was a bang average
diver but
like i i would always get jobs because i
was like just a laugh
and when you're stuck on a boat with
lads for 12 hours every day
if you make people laugh and you keep
everyone's spirits up
they're going to get your jobs they're
going to get him on his sound like right
so i got my jobs based on that and
ironically
like the youtuber in me probably helped
that helped
really because aside from being big and
strong you know i was still new at dive
in a lot like early on um
those people aren't very visible in the
world though are they like i don't find
that those people are like
portrayed in the mainstream quite a lot
and i do feel like those kind of people
get a bit forgotten because they are
quite important components of society
you need tough people
and you kind of bought that a bit with
you i think when you first started
youtube and even when you first started
the podcast
that your approach was just different to
to anyone else's
to life in terms of you were coming into
a bit of a media space where it's quite
you know hey very fast uh not and i
don't know in a camp way but i mean like
hey how are you doing oh kiss kiss
very furry yeah and that was quite alien
to you i [__] hated it like i was
like i wanna
like a creative people are usually lazy
in my opinion like right
so i wanted to bring the working-class
practical approach to
this and smash them together and i think
you know
you know when you look at successful
people in any creative industry it's
because they've got the drive
and of course that and um
yeah like in terms of those people the
one
one place i've seen them pretty well
represented
is a documentary called last breath on
netflix
where deep sea divers you know one of
them
there's a major accident basically if
you haven't seen it i highly recommend
it because
it gives a good idea of just what stone
faced kind of guys they are
and you know um
yeah there's a moment in the documentary
where one of them must have saved the
other one's life
and just by how matter-of-fact he is
like i think that'll blow people away a
little bit of like he's like
i just gotta move this thing from here
to here like and the guy's like lifeless
body is what he's talking about
but like you have to condense everything
down to like
a b and c yeah and just simplify and
just be really practical like in i did
admire the attitude of the lads and
stuff it's just it ain't who i
wanted to be forever jin and i mean well
what you do for your life
shapes you doesn't it like and i think
if you day in day out are doing a job
where
a you could die at any point and b
you it is about doing a b c and you will
achieve a b
c and therefore this money goes into
your account it's a little bit different
to the job that we do which is a bit
like
if you cover a z and t
then maybe we'll give you p so then
you're like this is why i think i've
massively overreacted
several several times right in our
working life
off camera like sure i'm known for
having a bit of a short fuse
because everything like before i would
go in the water
it would just be like check check check
check check check check check you got
good
like everything was just done no no one
could afford
to slack in any way shape or form
because you because
so i have been you know i was such a
young lad
it did shape who i was so i came in to
this industry
with that frame of mind of like well why
why not
why is this not like this what why not
like
the idea that there's money on the line
and that things just don't happen
it blew me away you know what i mean and
i think i still struggle with it
sometimes
because it wasn't even just a diving
before that
you know working as an apprentice
engineer and stuff like that being
around those kind of men
where things just happen and you don't
have to ask twice and it just
you know and then so when i come into
this industry
and like there's little tiny mistakes i
was just like [__] you remember
flying off the [__] handle and you
know
[__] me but that was i think like um
some people can put up with it and some
people can't like some people would just
go [__] this i can't take this amount of
stress not do
diving anymore or not do that because
i'd imagine that weighs on you quite a
bit which is why they are those kind of
characters because you kind of have to
dial certain things down
and dial other things up yeah i didn't i
think it definitely brought out the most
masculine side of me that's probably why
when we first started the podcast i was
such like i was so like that
you were very matter-of-fact about
everything you say and when you say
masculine you mean like sort of
doing and you know no i just mean like
traditionally masculine no it was like
military type blood you know what i mean
i was prop uh
that's just you know because my feminine
side had been so
you know yeah very much so so when i was
around a guy like you who was just chill
all of a sudden it was like oh yeah i
forgot about this side of me
strange though because you know when you
say you forgot about it
i definitely still like saw that in like
it was still in there still
in your eyes the whole time like you
never your eyes haven't changed is what
i would say
and i i don't mean that i mean like your
eyes are still the same eyes and we
would rover and i would talk about this
when we were editing how you watch
people over and over again you get
little idiosyncrasies
but your eyes haven't changed down all
the years and you've still got like
quite honest
quite loving eyes and you've always had
those yeah
i've got my mother's eyes yeah and so no
matter how much you were talking about
shagging the birds or like
going out for drinks and that like you
still said it with a
like a love in your eyes yeah because
i'm a loving person yeah and that's the
thing i think people don't get about me
is i genuinely like
care about people even though i say
things where it doesn't sound like it
right like i'm a i'm a
a complex [__] up person where on the
one hand i've been raised by a very
loving caring woman
who you know put so much into me in that
regard
but then i've been shaped by a lot of
different
working-class men who when i was away
working offshore
it was just like well graft would go out
with sink pines it was shag women and
that was what
it was do you know what i mean so they
sort of were
my dad's collectively many of them do
you know me and where they were giving
me that advice and
you know this is how you do this and i
took little bits off lots of different
father figures along the way
um it shapes your world though doesn't
it yeah it shows it makes you
like that's why maybe the media industry
didn't even occur to you because
those men and this isn't judgmental i'm
saying it doesn't even occur to them
to film themselves doing it because
that's just not well i mean
if you look in tv
youtube and all of that like i am an
absolute [__]
throw away like there is no one around
who is like that
really yeah like they tend to be sort of
more outliers
you're not the mainstream is what you're
saying these people would be more
the other way what i was interested
about though is i think digital
has also changed that because now
and let's face it like a lot of stuff
that you shoot on youtube this isn't
judgmental of youtube but like a lot of
stuff you shoot on youtube
you don't get it right you can just go
back to where you sit
you do it again you know when you first
started film
if you didn't expose the film right or
you overexposed it or underexposed it
and you're a famous actor like you know
back in the 50s
if you didn't get it right you just
[__] the film
and there were like whole interviews
i've watched with dops recently the
director of photography
where they go yeah so sometimes it was
just a total
risk and i was just really worried that
the scene just hadn't come out and i
completely [__] it
but then they're like but now with
digital and it's completely changed the
approach because people can be a lot
more
well you know we'll fix it in post or
whatever and it has sort of
it doesn't feel as life and death do you
know what i mean i think that was one
thing that benefited
me starting youtubers i used to when i
do like a little newcastle video
i would always one take it and if i made
a mistake i just start again
right and it's in from the very start
yeah
so if i did last minute
i'll just start again and do the ten
minutes okay
and i practiced and practiced some
practice and practice and practice and i
never really told anyone about this
but then when it come to being you know
doing
the wembley cup or you know these little
first little things are people seeing in
that look back
on the dre video i had practiced so much
that i was just
able to do one take immediately
um i you know make it a little tricky
because also
you also weren't willing to do more than
one take sometimes which also
could make it hard sometimes and
sometimes i mean even now sometimes you
turn to the cameraman rover and go if
you didn't get it we've just not got it
which is just so that's maybe difficult
it's true though like
uh it does sharpen you in a way and that
a lot of people message
especially during covid like um you know
i'm gonna start a podcast i'm gonna do
this
how do i get numbers now i was like
don't ask us but first of all don't ask
us because we'd have a bug
when people ask me advice on how to
start a podcast i'm always like
[__] me like get a microphone and just
start recording it
and put it on something and that it's
that simple
and don't think about what numbers
you're getting for it i know it's very
easy
well look you know like to take for
example uh the anthony podcast right
right
uh you're ma you've done a podcast with
them um loads of people we know have
done podcast
rory or louis van gaal he has he has
some medical issues
yeah okay doesn't matter he's got
himself up there and he's done it and
he's putting it out
and he's just putting his views out and
he that's that you know and he's getting
an audience yeah
and i look at him and i think look
that's exactly what i'm talking about
just do your [__] podcast put it out
and hopefully people like it he's a
doing man isn't he he's a man who does
credit yeah exactly i think that is
important shout out to him which is
watching we love him i mean he
definitely is watching blossom
and bell that's the point is you've got
to just be a doer and sometimes in our
industry you've got divers
funny my granddad gave me two bits of
advice when i was a young lad
and i've i've i've really hung on to
them actually and i wouldn't say you
know i'm not in
you know the brains of britain here but
but it really stuck with us and it was
bang on
he said brian there are two kinds of
people in this world
there are beers and doers don't be a
beer
be someone who does you know i mean and
and i know it sounds basic but
the more i grew up the more people i met
who were like i'm going to do this or
i'm going to do that or i'm going to do
the other
and never amounted to [__] you know what
i mean because they actually didn't put
the graft in
and the second thing he said to me
was if you're ever a manager of a
company employ people who are
self-motivated
because you don't want to have to
[__] motivate anyone you want people
who get up
do it themselves and don't need [__]
or swipe and all of that [__] yeah uh
because he was a manager of a company
actually
what company did he uh ironically he was
the manager of a cigarette company
really yeah because like they made
cigarettes yeah like back in the day
there was a huge cigarette factory up
north
that's cool top guys though he didn't
even smoke ironically that's hilarious
yeah
but that i you don't even think of that
now no it's mud doesn't it you don't
think first of all you don't even really
think of
people making cigarettes like that but
secondly like the fact that he was the
manager of a cigarette factory
i can instantly get his image in your
mind of him that's really cool
i was quite a lot like my granda um he
are you a big guy or not very broad
looking back at it you know the
the hairy chest and the thick legs and
stuff and the big back my grandma never
lifted weights but he always
he just had this like bare look to him
you know what i mean do you see what i'm
saying though
like i'm thinking a lot about what you
leave behind
and the thing you're talking to me about
is what your grandad said to you
not what you watched on tv last week
which i know influences you in the short
term but ultimately like
what your granddad said to you when you
look at a photo of him
that's like a legacy do you know what i
mean and i think we underestimate that
and i i watched the prince philip uh
prince phillips passed away
sorry for spoilers i'll watch the prince
philip um
how will it end stuff yeah the crown is
ruined for everyone
i watched the prince philip stuff and
the amount of time they were talking
about his legacy
and how much he left behind and all this
stuff and
why did you watch it uh i was morbidly
curious about who he was and i thought
uh
to be fair this is a historic event that
someone who will go down in history is
dying
i literally could give two shits about
me right yeah
but i'm not saying that to try and be
anti-royal no i get it it's just
genuinely like
i can't believe that i live in a country
where
some of my money every month gets taken
and it gets given to those
[__] cockroaches right i can't
[__] talk
i can't [__] believe it having said
that the point i was making
is definitely atheist of royalty
uh what i mean is
he he's he's an older guy who's got a
legacy to his own family
and it really i'm i'm just thinking a
lot about that at the moment
and part of me wonders whether taking
down the royals would be my
greatest legacy i mean i'm done if i
could leave that behind if we could
leave that behind not in like a guy
fawkes sort of way
yeah but i mean in like a you know
roving could be over
infiltrator although rowan's going to
film the whole thing yeah yeah
uh but what i'm saying is like legacy
wise you're talking about what your
granddad said and i imagine there are a
lot of people
and what i'm what i thought when i
looked at the philips stuff with why are
we heroing this guy
i had a granddad who was also interested
in science
he just didn't have a you know ronald
mckenna award
he just had he you know i mean prince
philip has got the duke of edinburgh
award
and i'm like so i mean what did you do
to get an award the royal family of
bollocks
and do you know do you know what do you
know what do you know what fascinates me
in a way didn't he what fascinates me
about it is in social media
you will often see things deliberately
promoted
on your timeline to make it look like
genuinely this is actually trending and
everyone cares about
i'll give you an example wwe yeah
no one really gives a [__] about the
wrestling right but for some reason it
trends
all the time how do you think that
happens because they're paying twitter
to make sure it [__] trends
the fact that the royal family or
whoever works with the royal family
clearly paid to promote the death of an
old man to make sure that it appears
like everyone still gives a [__] so that
we will all end up talking about it as
we are right now and going
no one cares we no one gives a [__]
right very few people give a [__] about
this old man he was insignificant
most of his life yeah like even to her
he was a bystander
the main event which was her and even
show you the jack [__] sure
she sat back took the money while the
prime ministers took the fall one by one
seen the crown i have actually all right
okay what did you make of it
uh it was actually fairly entertaining
right but
not no it didn't make you think oh the
queen's amazing no it's just
sort of chewing gum for the brain it was
it was like
you know basically the long story short
here
uh he was a bastard too well when he was
younger
she's quite um cold un uh emotional
woman
really um her sister was a shagger and a
drunk
was that mayor what was her sister
whatever
charles is a complete let down to them
and a bit of a loser and he doesn't man
up the way
uh philip wants them to right they then
put diana in front of him despite
clearly
he wants to shag camilla diana is then
struggling yeah poor life decisions
right okay they take all the money and
ultimately what i find weird about it is
because they have all the money
we think their stories are only
different to ours but actually
if if you put that same story in a
council estate people would have judged
it differently
it's true though i mean they're
literally on the biggest accounts of the
state in the world because it is council
funded genuinely yeah like
but that's my point is if you took that
story and you and you put it on like
what poor people
are people will be so judgmental of that
but because it's the queen and because
of the royal family they go
what she's been through good god
what are your life makes me [__] sick
is it really like
aren't you angry no math psychology
pisses me off if there's one thing i've
learned in the last two years
it's just the way like group thing is it
does my head in right people are so
easily just like
like we're giving money every month to a
family
because they're quote unquote royally
this is this is mental like so i don't
i've gotten to a stage now where i don't
engage in that i don't read it i don't
look at it same with kovid like i'm
completely powerless i don't talk about
it anymore like
it up in a way no i've given up because
the one thing i
i completely believe is like you just
gotta look after your own
and and you and hope that the rest of
the world don't [__] you over in the
process okay
i kind of get that like yeah like
honestly like there ain't no
oh we're all in this together
boulder dash [__] right [__]
balderdash would have been a great word
to use
having said that can i put it like do
you think the holistic side of you is
also growing as well
do you think that like you know while
you're doing the boxing and everything
else
uh do you think your emotional
intelligence is
uh thriving
in the same way as you wanted it to yeah
unfortunately
really what do you think is thriving i
just think i'm becoming more aware of
other people's feelings as i get older
well that's definitely true
yeah i agree with that i think you are
more aware of everyone else around you
now
sometimes that can be quite a painful
thing you know when you realize you've
hurt someone's feelings or
when you realize the situation isn't
what you thought it was or whatever
right it can be difficult um do you
think you're better at dealing with that
as well now though
i think the older you get the more you
take stuff to heart actually
i think when you're younger you can
brush stuff off and be a bit more like
yeah whatever next one life will change
yeah oh
yeah moving on who cares you know
whereas the when you get a bit older
i think you feel situations more
and maybe it's because when you're
younger you've just got so much strength
partially because of naivety partially
because the
time is on your side and every decision
you make can be undone or
redone or uh whereas at least it feels
that way yeah no i'm getting a bit older
i'm like okay
um you know if i hurt someone's feelings
or something like that
uh it means more to me and i think being
a better person means more to me than
what it used to
in every way actually right so i'm
really like focused on self development
and stuff like that and i think
i've always been someone who wanted to
be better year on year
and i think unfortunately some of that
is very much a struggle like as in like
if you're constantly trying to improve
everything about you
it will be difficult so like like i said
in that rebuild last episode i was like
i think i've just got to sort of try and
take things one
one challenge at a time or at least not
spin the plates quite as fast as what i
had been trying to because clearly that
wasn't working for us
and now i think i'm just cutting myself
a bit more slack but also just being
more aware
yeah probably i i think that's quite an
accurate description of probably what
you're going through right now
yeah yeah i had a bit of a moment um
which you know you know about a few
months ago where i just sort of had a
bit of a meltdown
and um i was just shouting a lot i was
unhappy i was
like upset uh frustrated
and yeah it was just that it was just a
awakening of like
this can't continue this like i'm not
i'm not good yeah i'm not good
me depression had just gotten right
ahold of us
and um
yeah it was it was bad do you know what
i mean so i think it was quite isolating
for you as well wasn't it because it's
very difficult
um i think is it like
probably geo and i were probably the
people who are closest to you or like
worked with you most in that time
and it was quite it's quite strange
because i guess the advice very often
like you say when
if depression takes hold of whatever you
want to say is
reach out to someone but that is
actually part of i think what your
problem was was it
depression can make it very difficult
also to reach out to people and it can
be
extremely isolating and it can make the
people around you feel isolated
so you don't really know what to do this
is the thing it's hard because
yes talk to someone is good advice
but the problem is is you know often
it is good people who have depression
partly because of that goodness like you
know they they're beating themselves up
because they are and the last thing they
want to do is tell their friend
hey mate all right yeah i think about
killing myself every day
right you know that in what you want to
put on to your friend and worry your
friend and then
and then create this whole big situation
so you just
shoulder it and you internalize it yeah
and keep it to yourself
and you start losing the will to carry
on so when
little things go wrong as they naturally
do in life
there was overreactions from me there
was anger
and then when other people so you're an
understanding person but if someone else
isn't understanding
and then they don't realize what i'm
going through
they then can't tailor their behavior a
bit to take the edge off
when they don't know i'm i'm ready to
[__] snap you know what i mean so
it was just difficult life was really
hard when you say snap you sort of mean
like just spiral
rather than you yeah but take care of it
i think snap sounds like i'm going to
turn up with a shotgun
yeah snap snap for me was more like
you know not wanting to live yeah
negative
like down miserable sadness you know
what i mean
and uh and yeah it's just
it's been a weird time really but
um yeah how did you like
every i'd say you know it got to a point
where every single day
i was having suicidal thoughts and like
it was sometimes multiple times a day
and it would just be like when things
were getting too much it was like
i know this this might sound [__] mad
right but i'm gonna say it anyway
it's okay because if it gets too much
you can just end your life
right and that was almost like a
comforting thing that i would tell
myself like
it's all right if this gets too much you
can just end it it's it
it almost became like a light at the end
of the tunnel like
like reverse yeah yeah so rather than
fearing death i was actually looking at
it like
[__] i've got that there if anything
like you know if i need it
which in in realistic terms is really
like that's
quite um it's not a sad place with quite
a dark
twisted yeah that shows the how how bad
it was
you know i mean that out that was an
anticipation not a fear
right and um and it was just constant
and the more things got difficult the
more things i felt weren't
how i wanted them to be in my life and
the the worse i felt
the more that got more and more and more
appealing and
darker and darker and darker and i
remember um
you know obviously things happen and
sometimes you're having a bad run or
whatever in life
and then one day i remember waking up
and i just had like a whole night of
nightmares and i was like
wow like what the [__]
like i just can't do this anymore like i
can't
like if i don't do something now
i'm definitely not going to see like i'm
not going to carry on
you know what i mean there will what all
i was waiting for
was um the moment for everything to
align for me to have a bad enough day to
just say [__] it
you know what i mean so you know i rang
the doctors up
and uh i basically told them everything
and i got an understanding
really that you know uh
there's depression that's like
circumstantial depression where
it may be triggered by something but
once that thing
sort of goes away or clears up or feels
better over time
your depression also goes away with that
yeah right and you go back to being the
sort of person you were before that that
event took place
but then there's uh clinical depression
and i think
you know clinical depression is a
chemical thing it's something that you
your brain is not you know chemically
balanced the way it needs to be so
therefore you're always going to be
depressed no matter what happens
throughout your day
and obviously for the longest time i was
putting it down to this i was putting it
down to that
you know and obviously i'd had a hard
few years i was like okay
it'll get better it'll get better it'll
get better and it just was getting worse
and worse and worse
and the prescribed as some
antidepressants
so i was like [__] me at this point i'll
[__] try anything
like any i'll try anything yeah i'm so
[__] sick of this
so i took them first week
was weird because they started off in a
lower dose
of antidepressants to sort of almost
like easy
i know it sounds strange but let's just
ease you into these antidepressants i
see why
so what was the i felt dizzy as [__] for
the first week
i remember you saying that every time
you get up even like i think
i'm not being mean when i say this but
you weren't always 100 sort of
present in that first week if that makes
sense you were still talking
but you weren't always um there wasn't
that quite the same like drive that i
guess i was used to if that makes sense
if if if you feel dizzy as like do you
know you remember the fairground
the thing called the waltzer yeah and
they'd spin you really fast around on it
and then you'd get off and you'd be like
whoa
the whole week that was what it was like
a lot even when you're trying to go to
sleep and like you're
yeah this must oh so that was another
thing my sleeping pattern was completely
[__] ruined i've got like
i went from getting like a good six
seven eight hours to
four max right and then i'd be a week is
that four
like you and then you wake up and just
be awake from three a.m and then you
just can't get back to sleep yeah
um not the only problem either right
as in you couldn't even get yourself off
to sleep yeah yeah yeah
yeah there was like let's just leave it
at that
lethargy of something yeah the the the
cop wasn't great
but does it also does that stop your
mental need for that as well or did you
still have the mental need
i i think yeah you still get yeah it was
just you still look at things and well
that's all right but like physically
it was just hard to achieve i don't know
how to put it
long long story short is yeah you can
get an erection but it may not be like
the same or if you try and do anything
with it you may
you know just wasting your [__] time
right so it was
that wasn't even like like put it this
way bro
i enjoy sex yeah it's a very big part of
my life
and it's important everyone yeah for me
to just go yeah
[__] it i don't even care that's how bad
i felt meant that's one of your three
pillars gone
isn't it genuinely like as a man when
you can't even do that and it's just
like nah [__] it
i was like if i don't do something about
this i am literally gonna end up dead
so i gave it a shot you know what i mean
and yeah i wanted to weigh it before we
spoke about this
um because i knew inevitably we'd share
it because we do talk about mental
health a lot but
i also wanted to know how this was going
to go before i even mentioned i was on
them
um and yeah that that the beginning was
rough
felt a bit hung over our first couple of
weeks yeah
but the suicidal thoughts
got better yeah but fairly quickly
actually
fairly within about two weeks i started
noticing oh i'm i'm not
i'm not thinking about it as much and
when you're reflecting on them now
do you do you think you you're
developing ways to kind of catch
yourself if you do end up going down
that route together or like
you're more aware of it now no i'm i'm i
mean i'm still on the meds they
they're up the dosage after um i think
was a month
and um i've definitely
felt look life is life you have good
days and bad days that is not what this
stops
you know what i mean it doesn't mean
you're constantly happy
at all if anything you know it i just
feel like
it makes me a bit more like the way i
used to be
before i had the depression and it made
me realize like all this time
that i was thinking oh this made us down
or this made us down
and maybe that played a part because
obviously post-traumatic stress
disorder which i've had multiple times
is a factor in sort of permanently
changing your brain
um but this definitely seemed to
cushion those bad days and uh
and just make me feel less like i'd wake
up in the morning
feeling like i wanted to die and now i
don't
you know what i mean i'm i'm not saying
i'm great
but it's not as bad for sure
and uh and i'm very grateful they have
the tablets like and and
you know it's just been such a weird
experience for me to finally
go and take them because obviously for a
long
time i was like you know i'm a man at
the end of the day my legs got to be
falling off before i
i ring a doctor and there is that white
like weird mixture of kind of
yeah the more masculine side of you not
wanting to go down that route well
you know because i'm attached to my mind
and and as a
creator especially like you feel like
everything you are is your brain
ultimately like
you know anyone does and you know
when you need tablets to feel all right
there's a certain stigma that comes with
that which is exactly why i'm talking
about it right now
because when i told certain friends of
mine that i was on them
like a lot of people like all right yeah
yeah cool good job but there was a
couple of mates who
were just like what like as if i was
like i had a lobotomy
right you know like as if my half of my
brain had been operated on or whatever
like i was like no no it's all right
like they're actually helping us a bit
yeah but they were like are you sure
right and then still it was like i don't
agree with that like it's just
you know and i was like like i'm
i'm all right it's still me you know but
that's kind of it's also
you haven't lost me but that's what i
guess some people do
some people don't react very well to
change in other people's lives
so even like what's strange about it is
if you are depressed and then you tell
someone you're about to change
that can change the parameters in their
world if that makes sense well
also i think you know some people who
are
scared to try them themselves and maybe
need them themselves
are possibly
you know a bit wary of it and it
frightens them a little bit maybe but
you know it look it was a difficult
first month and
uh and since then it look i it ain't
been rosy and i didn't it doesn't just
turn everything great but
i just think it it's the dramatic
of how low it got for me right it
has it's taken the edge off in that
regard and uh
you know now when i feel down look i
might still have the odd thought like
that but
but the frequency and you know i can say
this now because
i feel like i'm better not not great but
better
it was unbelievable how often and how
bad the anxiety was and how bad the low
moods were
and like i wouldn't wish that on anyone
you know what i mean
because like i i get for like other
people watching it's like well you know
you're doing well you've got this on the
other good
but it's like none of it mad it i
couldn't shake it like it was just like
i do not want to be here which also
shows like how little
how much and how little those things
mean around you like that like how it's
actually just about
there is a spiritual side that you need
to fulfill there is like a personal side
that you need for
no matter how many youtube videos you
can put out no matter how many views you
get all those things
it wasn't really about that element of
it yeah like
i there was a chemical issue as far as
i'm concerned because now
i'm just like the the how i was able to
do what i was doing
not actually wanting to really live
you know was it's quite something to be
fair it was yeah um
and i think you know the lockdowns and
stuff definitely didn't help either
um do you think you sometimes you are
sort of like
where do you think that um like uh
do you do you think you may have been
predisposed to at some point reached
this point in your life i don't mean
like destined for it but do you think
there is like something in you that
you know mentally maybe you might be
genetically more predisposed to be
depressed or any of these things because
i i definitely think that
some of this can run in a family and i
don't know whether it's nature or
nurture is the only thing
ah i mean i think with everything it's
probably a bit of both to be honest with
you but i think
i'm someone who considers a lot and
thinks a lot and i live in my own head
and i definitely talk to myself a lot
and have like long form
podcasts yeah yeah with myself i'm that
type of person
so i think people who are deep thinkers
they're the ones to watch out for
you know happy go lucky take it easy
kind of people
i feel like they're less likely to
reflect as much and it's
it's the people who look back a lot and
the people who worry about the future a
lot
they're the ones who are more likely to
get depression
right people who live in the now those
[__] those lucky bastards
they're the ones who i think are doing
it right but it's very very difficult to
do that when
you do have regrets about the past or
you do
have heartache in your past and you are
worried about the future and
fear of the future and for some people
it just gets a hold of them a hell of a
lot more
and are you a bit more present now then
so you're more
like living yeah yeah i'm trying to i'm
i mean you know it ain't my nature
you know what i mean like uh you know
what we've always been like even if we
do a really good youtube video i'm a bit
like what you said earlier about like
you know and i'm sure a lot of people
can relate
if if they're achieving something that
they're really happy with it makes them
feel on top of the world so
when a good youtube video goes up it's a
nice feeling
but it's such a short-lived one because
i am such a like everyday kind of
we need to do this this this and this
how long does that window last does you
even have a window of that anymore
because i think there is a point where
we've done i think we've probably done
the rebuild 2 or something like that
and i don't even think your window of
feeling good lasted more than 15 minutes
after the upload maybe
maybe not even that i actually think i
remember at the time you said to me i
don't even really feel that good about
that
yeah i think that was the height of my
depression yeah that was why
if i'm being completely honest i talked
about my mom in that
video was because i thought if i kill
myself
i want everyone to know what i thought
about my mom
like the lasting impression because
right now the way i'm feeling
i don't even give a [__] anymore and
that was something i'd held onto
for a while is that like a fear that you
wouldn't have
spoken about that like let that out yeah
it was sort of like
um yeah like
i attempt to you know without going too
deep into it
very much like she's my property she is
mine
forever and i didn't want to give her
over to the internet you know what i
mean but
that was the point that i'd reached that
was how low i'd gotten was it was like
this i don't know how much longer i've
got left here in my head like i was
genuinely just so low so i was like
[__] it i'm just going to put it out
there so that if anything if i do ever
do anything
at least that's that that's there people
know about that well because when you
talk about legacy
what i say in that video is if you want
to know who i really am i'm just a kid
who misses his mom
right and that in my head was what i
wanted people to think of me as
and that for me was a little bit of like
at the time like a goodbye message of
sorts like i know that might sound
mental because in the in the video i'm
doing boxing and i see him motivated and
all of that but like
that was part of the reason i left it in
general because i just felt like i don't
know how what the [__] going to happen
here
um which is a
that's a strange place very strange
place to be and if you're kind of
leaving very subtle
legacy messages behind doesn't it yeah
it's you never know why someone's doing
what they're doing really
you know what i mean which is why it is
very strange and especially when you
think of where you where you put it
and like like how
but that was just a freak thing that
happened and was caught on camera
and that was a moment where i had to
choose of like do i want to do this or
not
and i thought about it and thought about
and thought about it and i remember
there was just a day where it was like
rock bottom and that was when i was like
yeah i'm doing it
because i might not be able to do it in
a year's time or whatever so i'm doing
it
and how do you feel about it now like
are you still glad that you did it yeah
yeah i am i am i think a lot of people
since then have sort of
uh maybe realized more about why you are
the way that you are
since yeah and it was nice to sort of
let that out right you know what i mean
and really
let out the most personal thing
about me and i know a lot of people
wouldn't be able to do that
and and it's quite a powerful thing
like their strength and vulnerability
isn't do
did you ever look back at the first
podcasts that we did
and sort of the difference in your
demeanor then to and the stories even
that you tell
your focus on sex in those podcasts just
be absolutely is unbelievable
i know it's weird isn't it it's like i
don't know if i like that person do you
know what i mean so i tend to avoid them
i know i i had a very similar reaction
when i was watching this i do have
a dick the other you you know there's
some things i say and i'm like
you know [__] sake but right you know
also like i was just a young lad who
like i say i was literally fresh off of
a an industry that is just like that you
know what i mean so my whole
my whole attitude was masculinity
personified like so
uh it's funny i just wasn't ready to go
i wasn't mature you know there was a lot
of [__] that i had to get through and
deal with
and you know this was a fun adventure
and i didn't know how it was going to go
i think you savor it a bit more now but
in a different way
like if we were to treat making videos
as a steak
now you take the time
to make decisions about the steak you
want now
whereas i think in the past when you
first came down to london you get off
the train
we'd meet every week you'd insist on
shake shack
like religiously you'd insist that we
went to the same place
for the same preparation for the same
way
maybe maybe yeah i'd totally forgotten
about that yeah you
and we go to shake shack in covent
garden and we go through we line up
we go and sit down we chat we talk about
the podcast and then we get
an uber to the studio which was in
camden at the time and then
we'd do the podcast and then you'd go
and stay in hotel for the night and then
the next day you'd shoot and then you
just go home
and to think how much your life has
changed since then
is mad you haven't had shake shack in
years
it's amazing what you can do when you're
passionate about something that wasn't
yeah and that's what this all was is
like unlocking that and sort of like
discovering that you could do that but
that's why i managed to keep on going
during depression is because i am
passionate about this so it's like
right even when i don't like stuff
that like i don't like living i can
still
do this you know what i mean i've been
able to carry on doing the kickoff
and and and just for that moment be
true jody for that you know before going
back
i think that became that for a little
while became a bit of um
a ball and chains sort of scenario for
you though where you were like carrying
ground being true geordie for a little
while and i'm not sure if you're being
honest
whether you wanted to keep being
where whether you wanted to keep being
true geordie or whether you were sort of
you felt that was still holding you back
a little bit i really don't want to talk
like i'm
third person in this by the way so i
don't i don't
but i get what you mean you it became i
think for a little while
the image of you had become that you saw
and that you felt was not
that people saw you had become like a a
weight rather than
that character that had allowed you to
be so different to me i
i think i just hated myself right and
you didn't quite know where
the true geordie element ended and the
well yeah because you're evolving and
this is what i'm into self-development
but
the part of the problem is is when you
grow as a person and you look back at
what you used to be sometimes you hate
it and
and it's not that i'm you know a lot of
people fell in love with that character
and the person i was at the time
and they're still happy memories there
and i made them laugh and for that i'm
grateful
but there's just so many things i've
regretted in that time and
part of growing up being a man is
learning to live with those regrets
and sometimes that can be where i'm the
type of person to punish myself
internally and be like you did this you
did that you shouldn't have been like
this you shouldn't have been like that
like you know how does that resolve well
you know when you punish yourself
do you ever get anything out of that
like do you think that does allow you to
move on
there are lasting impacts hence the
depression you know what i mean because
of the scars that left yeah well yeah
because if you keep telling yourself
that you're a [__] person over and over
and over again
and that you are this and that you are
that eventually
it's just becomes your identity
and almost having people tell you you're
great
yeah it actually kind of weirdly makes
it worse because
it's like you go on camera you be this
person
because in that moment i go welcome back
to the kickoff or whatever
and we're having a laugh with the boys
and for that moment and i am happy being
with the boys like i'm being
fake because it's nice to be with the
boys but but once you go back back into
normality
you know it's like when you read youtube
comments or whatever you know sometimes
you can read nice ones and be like yeah
but i feel like this but
sometimes you can if you're constantly
depressed and then you read bad comments
it's
reinforcing it so there was just a lot
of
a difficult situation to do because you
know
if if you've got depression and you are
in
any job it's difficult but youtube
is a weird one because there's constant
feedback there's feedback from other
people
there's feedback from the commenters
there's feedback from
your friends and then your own mentor
and then you're on am i am i living up
to the standard so it's a constant
review system every single week you
weren't happy with
the kickoff for quite a while i remember
a lot of shows you go
it wasn't quite the show that i wanted
to make or you you and then
more recently you started to go i think
that was the best show we've made in
ages then
yeah yeah i i guess the point i'm making
is just
uh not specifically about the kickoff
but battling depression while being in
front of camera
is is a strange thing to go through do
you know what i mean because
the whole point of depression is you
don't really want to do anything
the last thing you want to do is sit in
front of a camera
and be entertaining and and it's been
difficult to do that for as long as i
have now you know probably been battling
depression seriously for well over
a few years you know so you know it got
worse and worse almost as it went into
that and
uh yeah i mean it's um
i'm feeling more motivated now on these
tablets
and you know um i don't feel like a
different person i don't feel like i've
lost who i was
i still have my low days i just feel
like i've got a little bit
more protection from my own
negative thoughts because they're not as
dominant or as overbearing and my brain
is able to like one of the things that i
used to
enjoy most is if i had a drive and the
sun was shining
you put the window down put some nice
music on you know
he has the here's the thing i remember
like a year ago or whatever i did that
in the summer and i remember still
feeling
so [__] about myself and even like a
good tune where you're like yeah
like it did nothing for us it i still
felt like
i just put the wind up and i was just
like and but this is such a
but i couldn't even enjoy a tiny little
thing like that
i even that i was like
i think because it hit my at my peak of
being an [__]
i was driving around in a a flashy car
listening to cool tunes and you know
roof down and all of that [__]
i really hated that person so now when
i'd have the window down and the
sunshine
and the music on it reminded me of that
and i had a bit and i
hated that guy so even when
and obviously that guy is me i'm not
sort of detaching from it i'm just
saying like
it i'd grown from where i was there so i
didn't want to remind myself of like i
didn't want to
get carried away again or i'll go back
to those all bad
habits you know what i mean so even
those sort of things made me like
yeah it's a bit like that phoenix story
where like phoenix
everyone thinks of like the phoenix
rising from the flames as if the flames
are a bad thing but apparently the
flames are a good thing is it burning
off all the stuff it doesn't need
and like in many ways you're like you're
shedding yourself of
that in your self-image of being that
guy in the car those kind of things that
you didn't really like i've done this
many times throughout my life though
yeah
because like it's something i am prone
to doing so like when i left high school
i felt a certain way about that person
in high school so i tried to reinvent
myself
in college as a better version of myself
and
you know this is a new chance and you
start yada yada and
you know maybe the same in diving and
maybe and then after after diving i try
to reinvent myself and in youtube i'm
now trying to
be a different version of that and then
we went to twitch and then you thought
well this is the first start
i'm not saying i look at everything like
fresh start and that i don't take
accountability for the past what i'm
saying is
i'm very aware of what i used to be or
who i have been
and i think about it a lot and i try and
be better
and this is the most i've ever really
tried to be a better person in my life
and treat people better
and i think since going on the tablets
that was another thing is like
the week before i went on the tablets
was like a real low point like i
remember
raising my voice a lot and now
i think i'm much more in control of
myself oh yeah definitely
yeah yeah the sad thing is is
in in that time my dad's also been going
through a really bad time
with his mental health and
literally just as i'd started on the
tabletop i mean a couple of weeks
um just cut me the chase
my dad attempted suicide
and uh yeah it was
just really strange
to go through that like all at the same
time like i'm
feeling the way i'm feeling especially
when you're changing the way that you're
feeling oh well i was trying to
obviously it was still very early
um i don't know uh really how
detailed you want to go but like kind of
when that happened like what
yeah i mean i don't want to go too
in-depth for people because i know it
can be quite triggering but
how did you feel being around that at
that time
yeah well okay so basic details are
i became aware through some text
messages he sent us that
um you know what he was thinking about
what he was going to do
and luckily i rang an ambulance
immediately
and the ambulance got to him and
took him in and they managed to
look after him and save him basically
and uh
just strange i mean i've told people my
dad about my dad's mental health
problems in the past
bipolar is what he suffers from and it
is the worst kind of bipolar
um but this isn't something that is
my dad you know like he's
you know he's like kanye's hypeberry's
creative he's
up and down up and down but not like not
that down
you know he's if anything he's been
terrified of death
his whole life he's the biggest
self-preservationist you've ever met you
know
um so for him they just say [__] it it
was like a real
wow you know what what the [__]
happened here then
because it it ain't like him that you
know
and when it's your own dad you know
saying that's it i've had enough
yeah it can blow you away you know what
i mean it was just like
[__] hell like i'm going through all
this myself and then my dad's feeling
like that and
now you know and i'm having to
constantly ring
you know the ambulance and is he all
right yada yadda
um and
basically like he'd hit rock bottom
and i really knew that by the because he
was just different anything i'd ever
heard before do you know i mean it was
like
no one cares there's just no point i
give up sort of thing
and obviously like you you say
everything you can but like i know
personally there's nothing
there's almost there's just no magic
word do you know what i mean and
my dad was clearly like you really
needed proper help because
i had a phone call with him the day
after
and in the space of like 30 or 60
seconds
he'd go from crying like
awfully to laughing hysterically
and it was just like the strangest
conversation of me life like
it clearly had just gone gina and i mean
like
and we but you were having a
conversation that way yeah
i was on the phone for about half hour
to an hour and just trying to talk
around and trying to help but
he wasn't like himself at all like
bipolar is such a strange thing and
um yeah it was just
like i can't explain it like it was just
freaking me out bro like i was like
one minute he's crying saying there's no
point and then like
half a minute later it's like well you
know what i'm like like
and i was like what the [__] like how do
i
deal with this like what are what what
you know also what's the expectation
yeah i mean you know i'm a man and and i
like to think that in most situations i
keep me cool
i know what to do but this was just
another level that anything i'd ever
experienced before and it went
by the way that carried on the entire
conversation like jekyll and hyde jekyll
and hyde flip-flop flip-flop
like there's no point crying crying then
laughing laughing then just back and
forward and it was just like
wow like
you know because my dad's been on
medication for [__] 20 years or
whatever it is like
so i've not really seen it to that level
before where like
we have a serious problem here and
in just like he's feeling down there's
just a like this is just
yeah you don't really know what he's
feeling at that point you mean you know
there's a problem but you don't really
know what he's feeling because it's so
i've never talked to anyone who had
lost their mind like that before where
you know i was like peter pan chasing
after the shadow on the on the wall like
that like where are you dad like
who the [__] am i talking to here like
that's actually really feels very
relevant
like i was just i couldn't pin him down
i couldn't keep him
in one place at one time on a level
playing field like
he was see-sawing all over in this
conversation
and like we were able to talk but his
emotions were just so erratic
and then i was like you know i was
trying to be like
it's difficult because i'm his son but
you know people who listened long enough
know we've had a
relationship which was difficult
obviously when i was younger
i went a long time without seeing him
but yeah i'm still his son but like
i'm also having to accommodate as like
the parent
because that happens everyone's at some
point in everyone's life doesn't it but
it's
particularly hard in this it does it
does but it
you know it was i was trying to sort of
what have you done that for you stupid
idiot like
trying to be sort of calm
yeah about a situation that isn't calm
you know and trying to be like oh yeah
my dad yeah i love you and
you know and and everyone you know and
reminding them and stuff like that and
but like he was just so like this is
over like i don't want to do this
anymore like it was really hard
to talk to him and um
yeah the the team were keeping an eye on
him and
um there's a crisis team and they keep
an eye on him and
they're very aware of what's going on
and then they sort of start tweaking the
medication and all that and that
but long story short something else
happened a few days later
and i was just like i'm like are you
[__]
do you know what you're doing here with
him because he's a serious man me dad
like you know i was like
um i'm gonna keep it honest i said he's
[__] hurt
people physically in his life and you
know you better know what you're
handling here and i said i ain't seen
any improvement he's getting worse
yeah and um and they were like yeah
we're very aware of that
you know we are paying attention i was
like okay
because you know i don't know what the
[__] best firm
it's like you know i'm i'm i'm relaying
everything i can't to them they'd say
look this is what he's like normally
this is what he's like now
what's up and then they they sectioned
them a day later
which does that they have to basically
get
a signature off of you know doctor etc
and
basically by law you're getting locked
up in
a mental hospital and inside this mental
hospital
you know it doesn't it looks a lot like
a prison
you know what i mean in his room and
stuff like that there ain't it's not
like [__]
it's not sitting there with playstations
and [__] like that you know i mean it's
pretty miserable
and you know if you are feeling down
it's probably not going to cheer you
[__] up if i'm honest with you right so
you know
whether or not that was the best thing
to happen it
it it it made me feel like look these
are the professionals
he's in the right hands they're gonna
know what to do
do you know what i mean so it's been
it's been really a challenging couple of
uh
couple of months um that's a lot to deal
with as well especially when you're
having a conversation with someone like
that because
i can kind of uh you know you can hear
in your voice but like
you want to tell someone you love them
on the phone and you want to have a
normal conversation with them and you
almost want to go like come on dad snap
out of it sort of thing and you can't
really do that but at the same time
it's a bit of a minefield of a
conversation because you don't know that
what you might say
could be a a triggering thing or could
be
you you know you're being very careful
with what you say to that person as well
it's very hard because not only that
like
he is needing me to be there for him
and there's been many occasions where
i've needed him to be there for me
and he hasn't been and it's been it hurt
me and he knows and look but
he knows you squared that way as best i
can
you know um
it's difficult you know what i mean but
i've been as good a son as i can be
considering
what has gone on in the past and
it it is hard because i'm like i want to
be there for you
you know and there's certain things that
i was saying to try and make them feel
better but
you know um it's difficult
you know because
he's let me down sometimes in his life
and he knows that and
um and now i'm sort of in this weird
position where i've sort of got to be
there for him
and um
yeah it's it's hard it's it's just hard
like you know there's a
there's a lot of things going on and um
your relationship maybe wasn't quite in
the place to deal with this
as a thing i do love him and he knows
that
and um he just seemed to be getting
better which is good
finally um and you know he's had a few
wobbles and um
some of the phone conversations have
been you know even a little bit funny at
times you know you have to find the
the humor in situations sometimes like
you know there's
someone dropping off his laundry in his
room and i'm on the phone and i'm like
are you all right dad and he's like yeah
i'm totally chilled i'm absolutely fine
and i'm like
you know there's part of me that's like
is he just saying this for me right and
then
and then he's like yeah i'm on the phone
i'm on the phone and the porter or
whatever
leaves the room and he's like [__]
stupid prick and then i'd see him on the
[__] phone
and that's the level personality that
we've been looking for
you know what it is right that's partly
me you know like
you know yeah i have i have a very
bizarre
you know cocktail of personalities that
made me and that my mom was a very soft
and gentle and kind person and my dad is
wild
and in many ways it's strange because
that soft and gentle person that your
mum was is now helping you to deal with
the man that
matter your dad is absolutely yeah and
you know um
it is strange when someone has to the
level that he has had
those mental health issues and you know
it can be difficult and one thing you
have to realize
is sometimes when you've got someone in
your family who's like that is
there is no magic pill that will be
given to them they will not come out
and just be normal like he's always
going to have certain things about him
that are challenging for people around
him because
you know like i say he's like kanye like
he's just up and down and
intense and and and he's he he finds it
hard as well you know
and say from his point of view is
imagine like you know you're in a you're
in a a mental hospital but let's be real
you've been locked up and with everyone
else who gets locked up
they get a release date now that you
know that might be
30 [__] years down the road but he's
like you get put in here and you don't
know when the [__] you're getting now
ever
so you have nothing to aim for in that
sense yeah right and and
if you do the wrong thing to the nurses
or the doctors you know
you just [__] yourself because they're
less likely to trust you
and no one trusts the word you say it so
like
you're you're speaking but really
everyone takes everything you say with a
pinch of salt it's a catch-22 yeah
because if you're honest about how
you're feeling and you feel you go you
know i'm feeling depressed today then
they go
depressed okay he feels and everyone's
making the notes in the room but you
know you're condemning yourself
absolutely yeah so so do you lie and
get out and think you can deal with it
yourself which by the way you probably
can't trick mental health doctors
i'm sure they're only human though and
they do and i'm sure they get certain
things wrong let's be honest there's
yeah there's many times people have been
let out and done [__] before do you know
what i mean otherwise if we knew about
that if we knew about it we'd just fix
things instantly wouldn't we yeah
what annoyed me is i had um i had
conversations with them
about my dad's well-being and naturally
i was like look
i want to give you as much information
to help you as possible but what i don't
want you to do
is tell my dad any of this because
otherwise it might upset him yada yada
and
you know we i had those conversations by
the way i had conversations with like
five different [__] doctors right
and i had to keep repeating myself over
and over
my dad rings us up and he's like yeah
they're not letting us out they said one
of the main reasons was because of what
you said
and i'm like thanks for that surely
that's like one of the worst things you
can say to someone the first thing that
was the first thing they come out with
right
and i was like throwing me under the bus
because you don't want
my angry dad blaming you lot so you
rather implement me you [__] [__]
or whatever that's really bad though
yeah it's like me it'd [__] me off to be
honest with you but um
it's also because you've also taken like
quite a brave decision
to say something to someone that could
be it's being
the for one to bed of a term being cruel
to be kind so you're saying something's
hard
but you know it's for the best well and
those people have basically gone
thanks for that we're now going to use
it in the worst way possible yeah and
look there was multiple hours and hours
take you you remember
when we were in the middle of work and i
stopped work and i said look i've got to
take this call
yeah so many hours i've spent on the
phone with these people and
you know a lot of them have been
extremely kind and caring
people and everything you'd want to be
around a loved one who is having
uh you know an episode and um
but obviously somewhere along the line
the communications went and it's just
it's frustrating but i ain't gonna
[__] dwell on that
yeah ultimately that i get they're
trying their best and and
and i'm grateful for it it's just such a
it's not a nice thing to go through
but i think um
yeah i i think the the worst bit was
that night you know the worst bit is for
anyone
if you get a call or a text or anything
like that
where someone is on the brink
and you you're at a point of calling an
ambulance to uh you know and think and
you know i hope it gets there in time
that sort of [__]
um it's quite panicked sort of it's
quite a dark moment awful
awful and it hit me for weeks afterwards
yeah you could tell
yeah like just you know
and i was going through my own stuff as
well it requires people to be quite sort
of emotionally intelligent around you
and to kind of hear what you're going
through because
i'd imagine that it's also
because you know i think and i'll say
this and i mean it in the least flippant
way possible when someone tries to kill
themself and then it doesn't happen
you only really can be close to them to
understand what that means for them
because everyone else is going well they
didn't die and it's like
yeah but you don't understand everything
else that's gone on to get to that point
and so that can be that i imagine that
could be quite hard even from the
outside just observing
people just look oh he's alive aren't
you happy about it and that's
but that's not the feeling you're left
with is it well especially not with
someone who's as
seriously mentally ill as my dad is
right he's got like a lot of genuine
um issues like that so uh that's a hard
one though because
you know yeah from the outside it can be
a very people looking in it can be
yeah i was you know spending a lot of
time feeling that way myself and then my
dad's feeling that way and he
you know he literally went to do it and
you know luckily it didn't work and
and then you know this the whole month
afterwards it's just like
what is the point in living you know and
it just
it just takes a lot out of you you know
what i mean um
and you're not in the right mind space
to maybe try and find out what the point
is in living at that point because you
are
definitely not yeah and obviously i'm
trying to stay positive as possible for
him when i'm on the phone with him and
stuff like that
life's just got so many ups and downs
it's [__] crazy sometimes
you know and it does flip at some point
between the parent and the child
when the child has to start parenting
the parent and that becomes more and
more sort of
constant rather than uh you know every
now and again
you might have you know when you're
younger i remember this with my own
parents sort of having moments where you
know when you first
think of something that they can't think
of or like you've got a
this moment where it's like you know you
feel like you maybe have surpassed them
a bit
and it's quite a proud moment when
you're young but then as they're getting
older well it's when they get ill
that's the the reality checklist my
dad's ill yeah
and it's a strange one to feel like
responsible
because they are literally ringing me as
if i'm his dad and i'm like yeah
[__] madness but the sense of
mortality around it it's not just like
oh he's got a little cough here
it's like life and death is a really
serious thing
yeah and it's quite heavy for you to
deal with though yeah i mean
it's it's been strange but and i i
thought uh i told him i said
you know i might mention this on the
podcast because
we've been really open about stuff
mental mental health-wise and
i thought yeah it's important people
hear this because
i'm guaranteeing that lots of people
who've been through a suicide or an
attempted suicide
will be watching or listening so you
know
um luckily i'm getting a little bit
better
my dad seems to be getting a little bit
so you know that's one positive at least
it means there's going to be more true
news is that in the near future
you feel good now we can yeah even
podcasts i tend to avoid podcasts when
i'm really low which is why
they're so few and far between right but
um
it's been five years guys yeah um but no
but lately i have been trying to do more
pods because um
i am feeling a little bit more positive
and i am trying to
you know you did a good job of those by
the way like i feel like uh
it was elizabeth smart and who's the
other person she did jake paul
james arthur and james arthur yeah yeah
i like james arthur a lot he was a
bit of a kindred spirit you could kind
of tell that
and it was better for me not to be there
for that one because i feel like i would
have
not had that same kindred element that
you two had
but you both seem to uh see things quite
similarly and you definitely both have a
[__] you attitude to the rest of the
world at some point
yeah i i love that guy yeah he's a bit
of a brawl
now so we have the odd little message on
that and i think he's been
understandably misunderstood like i get
why people have that's a strange one
he's been understandably misunderstood
but i get it you get what i mean yeah
like i get why people haven't got him
yeah but i hope they get him a bit
better now
you know what i mean yeah and you want
that to you know what strange about it
is you want
um you want people to be able to just
shift and watch that podcast and see it
and
sometimes people can just be a bit
damning once they've made a decision
about someone that's like nope
the decision is made and he once made
this mistake
i feel like that's like that with about
jake paul a bit like i think that's why
loads of people couldn't quite say that
he was going to win the fight
which is bizarre for me i think it was
bizarre for all of us
because i was trying i was watching a
lot of people's preview videos
i'll be honest brian you were really
going against the grain if you know what
i mean like
especially with the like big-time pros
and stuff oh they all got it wrong yeah
but ultimately
[__] you but the point is it seemed
quite
obvious but i did feel like emotion was
clouding a lot of people's judgment what
i was trying to work out was
was it emotional the other way that was
clouding ours where we really wanted a
youtuber to win
right because i i watched the stream on
on twitch of the day yeah and um
some of the comments were coming in as i
was talking about jake and
why i thought he was going to win so
convincingly and they were like brian's
going to look so stupid when
ben smokes and i was rereading it like i
wonder like
even though i still but i think i get it
like i think
people say you in a ufc cage and they
say the ufc gloves
and they say that like joe rogan and the
whole production
and they're like this guy's a fighter
and they look at them like superheroes
yeah
and the reality is they're not like some
of them are on the level
but if you're able to take all that away
and i think because i've seen jake from
day one
and i've followed ben i i didn't give a
[__] about the fact that ben was the usa
fighter or any of that so this whole
thing about
oh he's so tough he took the shots with
the four ounce clubs
you know even in my my prediction video
i just broke it down
elementary like so straightforward like
ben can take punches yes he kind of
[__] give them though
right like and he this is boxing this is
the sport of punching
yeah yeah like i get that he can take
one but
unless the thing is like he's just gonna
wait until jake stops getting tired as
he's late
like the whole the whole notion that you
know
and the sad thing is is some people were
so gutted that they were proved
so badly wrong because let's be real the
first
the first proper punch jake landed on
the on the head
he went down he crumbled right
it didn't even take two or three punches
it took
one proper punch that's how easy it was
for jake
they're like oh it's a fix it was a fake
was and i'm like you're embarrassing
yourself
right you're like everyone gets it wrong
bro just just admit it
just the guy felt like a [__] tray
mate he felt like this
yeah like literally you can't fake
that's very hard to face
he woke up after he hit the floor but he
was out in that moment he was completely
gone
like unconscious and i actually think
ben's a great guy like i mean [__]
hating on them like but it just kind of
showed
it showed a the natural qualities that
jake has at boxing and how he is good
but it also showed like you know ben had
neglected those same striking elements
for so long
that when he needed to use them he
didn't have anything there and he didn't
have natural power
he was old bit out of shape and jake
beat the [__] out of him like and if
they'd if they when people say it was
stopped early i'm like
what were you the referee's job
is to save that fight
when he is no longer able to defend
himself he was stumbling
like like a 90 year old on a bus when
you want to know what yeah you know what
he's trying to get from
paul appall on the bus he's like he he
was like that
jake would have badly hurt him so the
strange thing is i think
the angle that we watched and the angle
that most people are watching
is head-on and when it's head-on the
gloves look a bit
higher because you're sort of i know the
top of the glove reaches like there
but when you watch from behind there's a
back angle that i watched that i went
that's why he stopped it yeah because
when he was behind it he couldn't walk
properly
and his hands kept doing this which you
couldn't see from the broadcast side
they kept going the ref kept going and
up and he'd go
yep and then they go almost straight
away
yeah really done um it's one of the
you know i've been getting crap off the
mma fans for for years but
that really was the cherry on the cake
like yeah but for so many of them they
tried so much [__] in my predictions
time and time and time again
and and and for the way jake just
devastated
him like in with ease with me with ease
right i can't think of where jake goes
next because i can't see anyone wanting
that fight
oh yeah they'll be i mean so i
i think he just moves up the level in
the mma striking so like
ben was a poor mma striker he now goes
to a better mma striker wow
or or you know there's like none like
so there's dylan dannis kid there's ksi
maybe
um there's let's be honest though ksi is
so
he's got so much stuff on if you're
making music and you're doing all this
different stuff
you need a good six months or however
many months to put in a proper
a proper camp to do that i'd back jake
to get in uh jj to get in shape
and yeah i'm not saying that but you
know what i mean yeah
you want that experience yeah yeah i i
you know
i'd back him to be i think he'd be ready
the amount of people who have gone well
nate
gibb didn't go down you're not actually
credit to give he was the only person
who didn't go down in the same way as
before
this is the thing you know gabe has got
a chin
like gibb got up three aims and you've
seen that in person
as well right yeah i've seen i've seen
gabe take some shots in the gym he's
hard as his [__] nails not good
he's fighting soon yes he's fighting um
that tick tock ladder and just because
he's fighting someone from tick tock
doesn't mean he's not hard
like this other tick tock lad looks he
looks good seriously good
yeah yeah he's got like good skills and
i've been impressed with some of the
tiny little clips i've seen of like
all right he's got the basics down he's
quite um
they say a cute fighter like he has like
little movement so i'm like oh
yeah that's nice yeah a little tight
he's he's tidy
you know what i mean whereas obviously
gabe is a is a
fighter he's just a force like yeah and
and this is the thing
if if you ain't ready for a fight and
you're fighting gabe he's going to win
you have to be ready for a fight to win
and
and credited like jake like this this
this this was the thing when i went back
to the prediction on
on the bend thing i was like people like
you you can't you can't call
what what jake's done and worth anything
because he hasn't fought anyone i'm like
i'm sorry he he's he's dropped people
he's actually dropped multiple people
ben's never dropped anyone
even in the early days never dropped
anyone i said 20
fights never dropped anyone two fights
dropped
three times each fight like the data you
know when we talk about the bruce sorry
about the data
i was like the date that's there yeah
it's [__] there
i never when i watched the button i was
like i think this is easy to break this
right it's like it's insane yeah yeah
when the table are like laughing and i'm
like he's gonna rip your head off yeah
it's like and he actually almost yeah
like if he'd been allowed to continue it
would have been well
yeah i was going to say about the early
stoppage if if that would been allowed
to continue
jake paul could have [__] like he
could have killed him
not like people die because they take
unnecessary punches after being
done and a blood thirst and often
bloodthirsty people who don't really
know about fighting want to see someone
completely wrecked and finished because
they're like
oh well no right well now he's rectified
i'm glad because i like
like ben so i don't want to say i'm
absolutely brutalizing you hate cte
yeah ben was ben was leaving on a
stretcher if they'd let that go another
[__] 10 seconds you see jake was
posturing like jake was rushing back in
and then and then the referee like steps
in almost like
you know what's strange about it the
referee was almost uh he was looking at
ben
and trying to get him to keep his arms
up and then the referee is like yeah
that'll do
what and then he sees jake steaming in
and goes it won't do it won't do
what's funny is everyone had a go at the
referee for not stopping the nate
robinson fight early enough
he let him up twice and then he got
literally flatlined
this time the referee got it right he he
saved this guy referee
um in retrospect wasn't he yeah so uh
credit credit to jake he actually uh he
messaged me saying that you should be
involved in the uh the next
thing like but what yeah i don't know
what he maybe he saw your avatar and he
thought i'll message rick ross and tell
him now
definitely not no definitely not very
much i think you know because
it may be something to do with the
debatable production
that was on the show sure yeah like we
can do a small room
but now what we're going to do is take
on a whole [__] warehouse of things
that's a good idea
what i will say is you need me to direct
absolutely if we are commentating at any
point
yeah i'm not saying we will be but i
don't think you'll
you'll hear me get my money jake yeah
get my money
my money give my mother [__] two
million i love that
you know what i think i will still enjoy
and
because it will be legal somewhere else
a passive high from snoop dogg
secondary secondary high whatever you
want to call it i
still enjoy hanging out next to him you
just you get buzzed exactly you're just
like thanks uncle
i'm pretty sure that's what the oscar de
la hoya who was clearly off his tits
yeah that was unusual wasn't it that was
unusual watching that back
that they allowed that to happen it was
right now i think they've gone full
entertainment
and don't really care about the boxing
yeah aside from the main event
yeah although you know they did get some
decent level boxes in there but
it didn't show up until they just talked
over it as if it was not even happening
right
well there were times they cut away from
it yeah it was so strange
i just i don't know if i feel like maybe
they want to get it more in the middle
you know what i mean there's a lot of
ideas right now and it's very it was
very much like watching
an idea soup yeah just on your screen
and at some point someone's gone and
there'll be lots of bums and everyone's
going okay bums yeah
i i was so much lost i'm not complaining
about that i've got no but there was a
lot of it there
was like a whole lot of big ass okay and
i get that but then there were a load of
old rappers
and i get that and i'm all for it let's
just shorten that down a little bit you
know
also like if you're gonna have like a
fight night
justin bieber ain't the guy is he i know
he's got clout and all of that
whoa no but let's go and you're like am
i are we doing it
should we not do aggressive music yeah
you know what i mean like get him
to cover lincoln park [__] sick yeah
it was it's bringing me to life
it's just weird isn't it it's just weird
so i i
totally hear you like it look like let's
just throw as much at the wall and hope
it sticks
and then in the middle of it all is what
was the comedian
uh called that ben guy was it better
sorry pete
oh pete what's pete's name
davidson pete davidson yeah he did it um
he was good because he was on screen
basically
making fun of the whole product no but i
think
what you and i do is like
we both make little inside jokes about
whoever's on screen
right but we also take it seriously we
also break the fight down we also
appreciate the athletes like you have a
a
one of the ogs of the usa in frank mia
who's getting into a boxing ring
things like that there's so much you can
talk about right
and i personally huge fan of frank we've
had him on the podcast that there's so
much you can do with that and
um the guy he was fighting i think was
uh one of the first people that dropped
tyson fury
there was a lot so you can you can do
sports chat with a little odd joke and a
little bit of a
tongue-in-cheek make a bit of fun of
jake make a bit of fun of ben
but that was just a roast and and
yeah don't get me wrong like as much as
some of the jokes were funny and
you obviously clearly had watched ricky
gervais and thought how am i gonna do
that sort of thing
in this setting but it was awkward it
wasn't
and if you've got like snoop dogg as
your boxing guy
and him as your host your main boxing
guy like no wonder it was a bit of a
[__] show dude there's two
spectrum as well i think you know what
you have to have is um
everyone who was on commentary was not
the self-sacrificing person you need to
do commentary
commentary people have to be willing to
hand the event to
to the images that are you exactly
bro and you know that you you are
literally
the salt and pepper and you're you're
not trying to bathe the show
the show is the show yeah you're there
to help it i do it season it
you ain't the show and i think there was
too many people
behind camera wanting to own that moment
and to pay the star yeah and and and
pete
obviously wanted to go and make a bit of
a statement as a comedian and and that's
what small comedians do and i get that
but
he ain't going to do it again now
because jake paul's like [__] that guy
who
i mean who knows that's the funny thing
is like who knows because
everyone knew that was pete's comedy and
i think he's a big face in america
but i think in a couple of months jake
might look at that and go
i wasn't as bad as i thought i i did
hear that he brought up something an
inappropriate in the locker room
pre-fight that was bleeped out so wow i
i doubt it okay
right so to be fair all i'm saying is
pushing it me and you
me and you oh bro i will dye my head
blonde and wander around the event
causing utter offense to everyone uh the
show did huge numbers bro
he did like 1.5 million people of you
buys me
it's insane what he did like right now
you could argue jake paul is the biggest
draw
in boxing like because anthony joshua
without a good opponent probably doesn't
do a million buys
tyson fury the same jake paul could
fight a [__] broom and get over a
million
it's it's mental he's a stiff idiot but
this is like i said in my prediction of
something like
i was after i come out i was saying
something like no one gives a [__] about
canelo alvarez
like that's why they put alvarez i said
um i said jake paul's gonna outsell him
by trouble it turned out to be more like
[__] ten times
that's amazing right now it was ten
times and when people like
no one gives a [__] about canelo and
i've seen the odd little comment i'm
like you get what i mean
the mainstream like jake paul has become
the biggest star in boxing
can you [__] that that little brother
that we had on the podcast three
three years ago it wasn't even the main
event who sat here at one point
like he was he was a good guess actually
uh looking back at those podcasts when i
heard it in the back
i actually grew to like him even more so
so this is the thing that i originally
got under the j
thing about was because it's the whole
you are the person that we and and i i
think
i can appreciate someone for doing good
even like no matter i don't know what
you think about them or what the common
opinion is of them and i think
right now there's this sort of bad guy
image around him
and i i you know he plays up the camera
he says the odd conor mcgregor style
thing he can be a bit
cocky arrogant but like on on the
podcast i did with him i thought you
could you could really
see through that and and see the real
thing you see his intellect
on the podcast yeah in the same way as
when you've had uh jj on i thought you
could see how smart he was
and the same with logan i think any of
those guys
it's been um there's not really been
that front
up of like the fighter there's been like
the intellectual aspect of them
and they all have that by the way like
they're all really smart really like
eloquent guys and sometimes they just
get
pigeonholed and that's because when you
see a young kid making that kind of
money and
yes they've all been dicks on camera at
one point and been like silly
who hasn't but i think it's hard for
people to let go of that thing of
you are always that one thing i've seen
that of you
you can't be anything else now and it's
like these guys are media moguls with
teams around them
they're they're they're resilient they
are good with strategy
they have had to be resourceful because
they've never
just done one thing so all these boys
have tried their hands at loads of
different things
and and being just even being a big
youtuber you have to get good
at lots of different skills so
that is why like they're like a swiss
army knife for media they can do it
all editing production directing
like even just that they created before
so no wonder when these guys try their
hands at music
boxing or any other thing that they put
their mind to no doubt if logan went
into wrestling full-time would be a big
success whatever
they've just they're multi-talented and
and yes
they might not be singularly talented at
one thing
as good as canelo alvarez as a boxing or
as good at
music as justin bieber or whatever but
the point is is
i can appreciate what they've done and
as a youtuber myself
being fortunate enough to have them on
the show back in the day early on
to watch them grow and [__] and become
you know when logan's on wrestlemania
and jake paul's doing his [__] boxing
event and
then jj is [__] top of the charts in
the uk
you know you can't get in a [__] uber
right now by the way without a ksi song
being on
genuine and you're just like oh yeah
that's oh yeah
i prefer that one to the craig david one
just my favorite one was the uh
nathan dawes one okay yeah that was it
yeah that was a decent hit patience i
think is the best one
the gary parlow one
i'd love to see jj freestyle over the
top of that
yeah with auto tune and with the accent
one that he does the accent rap that he
does
um so yeah i'm i'm happy for them all
and i think it's
i think that was partly what i enjoyed
is
that the feeling beforehand
people weren't looking at the skills of
jake paul and the skills of ben
yeah they were simply going a ufc
fighter cannot be chinned by a youtuber
that can't happen yeah and just to just
be like well watch
and as a youtuber myself it's like stop
putting people in boxes stop
stop discounting what people can do and
also stop putting yourself in there
yeah and that goes for everyone you know
what i mean
and i think it's great that when people
don't say limitations and
clearly those three guys do not because
they have done whatever the [__] they
want to do
um i love that because that's the
attitude i've got and that's
attitude that i think winners have
generally speaking of which
it was really good to have joe weller
back on the show yeah it wasn't
genuinely like i feel like um you know
you two have always had a great
relationship and it's always been nice
to watch
but he's got such a great energy now and
i really enjoyed hanging out with him
in a way that maybe i hadn't really
before because he seemed so relaxed and
so
sort of he seemed very um
comfortable in his own skin you loved
every minute of it mate and
clearly and i loved him being here and
uh
i said oh my says we've got to get you
on another one do you know what i mean
and i know that there were people like
whoa
[__] uh joe's mortal and all that but
it's like bro
what the [__] do you do when you're
watching a fight like we we get
drunk we enjoy the night and also for me
and joe it was a bit like we hadn't seen
each other in a while locked down
so i think we were both getting
absolutely paced because
we were just happy to be like i'm gonna
laugh and yeah
catching up and talking about fighting
which is what we love and
especially a youtuber fight like you
know it brings back a lot of memories
and joe started it
so i [__] loved it i really enjoyed
it and you know what you can also tell
is
he's changed so much in the way that he
speaks because he has his own podcast
now
mm-hmm yeah like having your own podcast
let's not advertise it
we're not advertising it we you know
we're not saying it's called waffling or
whatever
it's it's good to see him doing well i
enjoy hanging out with jose um
i'm just looking at what people have
sent us to talk about now you're a
request section
oh oh sorry no um people said um
what uh talk about the beats video deal
didn't they oh did we do a piece by
radio yeah we we signed with
with what these bad boys are these bad
boys what these oh
smoking they are actually if so first of
all
they're great headphones and they're
really good to do podcasts with
uh so if you enjoy doing a podcast well
though then uh
they look great on while you're on
probably should get the
probably should get the main probably
should get the star yeah probably should
get there well you've
really got that so get brian now um
uh yeah i'm i'm pretty buzzing with that
what for one of your childhood heroes
uh name to be on the side of your your
own brand on that yeah right that makes
sense [__] mental mate
it was pretty insane wasn't it when they
first sort of got in contact and went
yeah we're thinking we we like what you
do
uh yeah i want to give a shout out to
the pizza by dream boys because
um they have been lovely from day one
and
um they really
care about the content as well like
they're not like
um can you change this to make it look a
bit more yeah
they were like we just want you to keep
being you
and that's it yeah and like and i was
like what about the
controversial he's like fine that's what
if anything that enhanced the deal
that actually surprised me like because
you know having a company with the the
fingerprints of
uh dr dreon it was it was built on
rebellion it was built on not giving a
[__]
you know so i think that they look for
characters who are
you know not just going to be goody good
boys on youtube you know what i mean
like so
and i do i do remember i think one of
the first things that they talked to us
about
was the fall of true geordie video which
really made me smile because that was
such a low point when i made that video
and um there was so much music we used
and even there is even a line where i go
driving in my car listening to dr dre
right yeah and i actually said that
in that video so for them to watch that
and be thinking about and use 50 cent
music in there which was produced by dr
dre
well that was one little thing loads of
people got in the comments were like
that isn't even
the trails like it was produced by drew
thank you very much it's also quite
weird because
we left with the with the video with the
the next episode video that we
launched it with or sort of formally
announced it with because we've been
wearing the headphones for ages in case
no one had noticed
like uh we used all the dr dre songs for
that and then by the end of the video
you realize why
um and loads of people i thought you
were using a lot of dr dre in this video
which was great fun to be able to edit
to something like that
yeah it's nice to have those little
easter eggs and stuff there for people
who
sort of not realize why it's called the
next episode
until the very last second of a 19
minute video or whatever it was
you know else i realized when editing
that together not to go back really back
to the start of the podcast but like
how many different subjects are covered
in one podcast and how many different
aspects of each person's personality is
shown
and the the real struggle was or not the
struggle but like the task and the
challenge was to knit all those things
together
because one podcast you've got you know
frank mia who's sitting there
he just loved life when he was on our
show and the next second you've got
someone who's sitting there who's lost a
parent or
has you know lost their loved one or
spent 26 years in prison and you're like
how do i get one thread throughout that
whole thing
but there were a lot of commonalities in
everyone's experiences so matter no
matter what their suffering was no
matter what their
you know their challenge in life they
all had
there was something you could see as
like a blueprint as to it was quite
heartening to watch
that's what made me think when i watched
your edit i remember thinking
we're all the same really aren't we yeah
it really made me feel that way when you
watch them and how similar people's
solutions and experiences it's quite
nice
i think i find it hard to connect with
people sometimes so that was nice to see
that and the way
you guys strung it together and and
created your own
jigsaw out of a whole load of what
seemed like random moments
yeah and it shows what a [__] smart
dude you are because you were able to
piece things together and go right this
year this year and then
i would just come along and go oh you
tried that try that yeah
but turn that up you've been basically
yeah
but um yeah it was
it it was a special video that it really
really was
and it was so funny when people were
like um some of the comments were like
when will this guy stop making
documentaries about himself i'm not not
true
actually i didn't make the documentary
so i literally just sat back
yeah it's commissioned someone else to
make this so the joke's on you it's it
was like sampling
and the funny thing was it was a bit
like sampling in hip-hop
like where you start to like you listen
to a whole song and then you go oh i
like
that bit i'll take that and then pair
that up very much
in those things well you basically were
were kanye for that
you were making your own you know
amalgamation of footage and music and
you know a movie almost and i think it
was
extremely challenging for you as well
because
you you seem to get to a point where it
was like
so much was right but you just were
missing that one little bit and it's
like oh how do we get
you know and i think people when you
watch it in one go
it seems so smooth but that's be like
like any bit of
like this table for example it seems so
smooth because someone's worked on it
and smoothed it and smoothed it
for weeks and weeks and weeks you're not
to get it to get it perfect like that
and
i am lucky that i i know the work that
went into it you know because when we f
is fed so when we first watched it there
were so many different
bits that were just not they just didn't
fit together
and it's hard to um like piece them
together
and you know the strange thing i always
struggle with with editing and i think
is the creative process in general
is when you come to share it with
someone else it changes the way you
think about it and it changes how you
like are piecing things together because
you start to take another input into it
and it starts to change how you start to
piece stuff together
yeah and it's it was it's a really
strange experience similar with any
anyone's editing but editing in the
first place [__] with your head
and if you edit for long enough it just
messes up yeah
but specifically when you're editing a
creative piece and that's the thing that
a lot of editors don't
don't get to do because they're editing
they were brief and that and it's
here's the footage make this dumb right
you
you literally had hundreds of videos to
go through
and and no no blueprint there
it was simply i know it was dr dre not
jay-z make it as you
as you go almost structure it as it's
happening so
so i think i think another thing that
conflicts with with the mind is like
when you're a creative person you very
rarely find creative people
or extremely organized people as well so
what you're trying to do is force your
brain
to do two completely different things
which is stay organized
and to make sure that this follows a
structure while
creating that structure at the same time
and it's just
that was a real challenge it's difficult
that was a real challenge in the first
few weeks we found this when trying to
edit it together because you'd be
watching a podcast and you
find like two or three clips out of it
and then you go to place one clip and
then you'd be placing that clip and find
an
it would make a thread and then you'd
think i could do this and you just get
off on so many different tangents of
like well that's where
uh that's where chris eubank can go and
then this guy can go here
and at the start of the day you'd
actually just wanted to put frank mia
where he was meant to go
and 20 minutes later you've got christie
bank here and like five other people and
frank may doesn't even fit into that bit
anymore
so it's like a strange it's more like
play-doh you know you're just like
trying to piece all these bits together
and make a dog but you end up making a
cat in the end
what a beautiful cat though i'm i'm more
than happy with it
and i know a bitter and um yeah and
going back to the
the deal you know when they got in
contact it was
it was like getting the call from like
the queen or something right yeah
for like for other people yeah um for my
nana
uh yeah yeah like i was like
you don't get what you've done here yeah
you know what i mean sort of
i i've spoken at length many many times
on all podcasts where like religiously i
would listen to dre
like i grew up on eminem 50 cent dr dre
like i had the awardmen and every day
i'd put that dre 2001 album in and i'd
go back and listen to the chronic and
all of that and
all of the albums he produced and i
could tell you so many random facts
about dr dre and his music and stuff
so it was like wow like
i grew up loving hip hop and like to me
youtube
is the new hip hop it is that new form
of expression it is
where people are discovered now right
and hip hop is this sort of [__] now so
you know it i think it's just very
equivalent it's very similar to where
youtube
sometimes like the commercial side of
youtube is actually like hip-hop
commercial hip-hop seems to live on that
commercial side of youtube right now
strangely yeah and youtube weirdly like
pushes it despite the fact that
a lot of it is true actually yeah
so yeah no judgmental weight by the way
you know
i just feel really like like grateful to
be chosen and that and to
you know because it is it is a brand
i've always like enjoyed and loved and
yeah and you know there was a reason
when i watched the defiant ones which is
it's funny to say this now but i always
thought of me and you
like uh dre and jimmy and that like the
way they work together the way they
they help uh fit in with each other's
flows and and make it make
up for what each other's lacking but
also are both very strong in many ways
yeah uh and their partnership and all
the years and everything they achieved
and i was like
i love that that documentary
if anyone hasn't seen the defiant ones
it was like
yeah really made me think about what's
achievable in my own life
and to then be contacted by them after
seeing that documentary it's just
it's amazing my mind-blowing um
so yeah like that that that young kid
who wrote to school every day listening
to dre and now i'm
partnered with his company it's just
[__] what the [__]
like it's it's like almost impossible to
put into words but the strange thing is
they're paying you to put this sort of
thing into words so that's kind of
that's it's really disappointing
it's that bizarre to me like that is
bizarre
um but it ain't even about the money
this one like well this is actually
about
i think when they first came to us is
actually about opportunities and they
they've got a table of opportunities
that we can uh
mesh with them with and it's like you
know people and
uh you know rooms we can get in and
those kind of things you know and also
looking back you know i remember when we
we
we stopped working with a certain
company who said that i wasn't brandable
i wasn't
sellable and now to be working with
poker stars jim shark and beats by dre
who are you know triple a
like they are the best of the best at
every in what they do they're the best
all three and also me personally
like those companies enjoy working with
those companies you use all of those
products in that sense and i literally
like live in there
yes their stuff like you know and and
and
use the poker up and all of that like
it's just a great feeling and and to to
feel like i wasn't good enough back in
the day when
you know going back to that that guy who
you know was wild as [__] when you met
me and stuff like that and and
to a degree out i i get the criticism at
the time but there was no
like attitude of this kid's a diamond we
could work with them we could make them
this we could help sculpt them we could
you know there wasn't any attempt you
know i had to figure that all out for
myself but i'm glad i did because now i
don't have to cut those [__]
in boy yeah that's so true as well it's
like
they would have taken a whole big
percentage and now
you know where we're doing my own thing
and um and yeah it's a real proud moment
because like i'm a kid who were 10 years
old was told i was destined for prison
you know by my teacher and stuff like my
mom my parents evening heard stuff like
that and
it's like you know it just shows how
like and i think that's why i have the
attitude
people think um self-obsessed sometimes
or tell my story over and over sometimes
and
that's not what it's about it's about
like for me telling my story and
and luckily having a best mate who can
do what you can [__] do
i just want to show people what's
[__] possible you know what i mean
because i
i seen that growing up and i wasn't by
dr dre and by
other people who were written off were
you know working class guys from all
over the world and
we're told you will never be anything
and because they didn't take no for an
answer and they believed in themselves
they got somewhere it doesn't mean
you're gonna [__]
you know be michael jordan or whatever
but
you if you have that attitude and you
have a passion and you do that
then there's a good chance that you'll
get somewhere
which is better than [__] norway
which is where you'll get if you do [__]
all me
and the i think the main the main aspect
of uh
storytelling is finding things that
people can relate to and
experiences and known experiences and
the best thing to draw from is your own
life so
yeah if people can latch on to elements
of that which was like the
with this we were trying to make
something about the podcast not
necessarily broadly about everything
uh and all those different aspects sort
of them just fell into place i grew up
listening to eminem tell me about his
life
about his life who he was and it made me
care and i learned that through those
artists
because they talked about their
experiences over and over and over again
and people sort of project themselves
onto you and then it comes yeah
you relate to that person to that artist
whether they're a youtuber rapper or
whatever the [__] they're doing
filmmaker anything and
the when when i was trying to tell my
story like in those times i did it's
because i knew like
at some point people will
get me a bit better and that'll make
them care more and i'll develop a better
relationship with not only my audience
but also
outside of that and hence why
beats by dre say fall of true jody
like yeah yeah investing so when people
go mind you keep
your story it's like bro you don't get
the game mate
you don't [__] get the game i do and
that's why i'm doing it
you know what i mean that's a fun game
though isn't it yeah and
and and aside as some of my lives being
the ups and downs is how
it's made me and and to say obviously in
in
in the in the in the the way you put it
together
and obviously it doesn't explain
everything but you say those moments of
tears you see the highs and the laws and
yeah it's nice to watch back and and
that's a video
that you know when i'm an old man i'll
have and that's great that
it triggers some good memories as well
doesn't it it makes you it makes me feel
quite nostalgic about when the
millions started especially when you're
doing like you got express yourself in
the nwa music
when we first started podcasting that's
the that's the
the literal parallel we're drawing is
like we were the first guys in the uk
to do a video podcast and i really
kicked the [__] out of podcasting in the
uk
and you know i'm not saying i'm the
[__] doctor trey of youtube by any
means but
draw those equivalents there you go you
want to say that no but you know you
know
but what i'm saying is we were just two
kids you know who didn't give a [__] and
we're just like
out there and that's when we do look
back at ourselves and i have said some
of the mad [__] i've said
and i do go [__] me you know
yeah but that's part of growing up
that's part of being a wild kid and if i
wasn't that person i would never have
kept going and being who i was you know
yeah it's been a good ride so far
hey brian did you know that manscaped is
now available in the uk yeah a lot of
people do now because manscape has been
advertising in the uk for a little while
but what they might not know
is that manscape has lots of great
products it's not just about say
shaving your balls that's what most
people think it is right because it's
called manscaped
but they think of the hairy parts in
their body but not every man has seen
every
hairy part in his body that's because
it's all sexualized right isn't it
is the nose sexualized stop thinking
about penis exactly think about it get
out your dirty minds
the weed whacker right this looks like a
cocoa
oh see smart and not many men are very
conscious of their nose hair it's
minimal effort for maximum results
exactly yeah and the maximum result
being that when someone looks at you or
you even look at yourself in the mirror
bam if you want to trim your chest hair
your armpit hair
your head here
the point i'm making yeah that's
specifically for that the nostrils
specifically this would be incredibly
slow on the balls they've got every hour
they've got everything covered yeah
exactly yeah like the lawnmower 3.0
which is like a bigger
better version of this but can we not
describe it they'll show it on there
show it show it the point is that you
can go to manscape.com forward slash
true do you know what you'll find there
you won't believe it doesn't believe
this is a great discount 20 percent off
and free shipping your world free
shipping it's the shipping that costs a
lot right now
all right it's the shipping the shipping
is always the thing that gets you
you get to the checkout and you go oh
the shipping
stung me do you know what with manscape
it doesn't sting because it's perfectly
well engineered exactly and
free shipping boom go get this go get
the lumber 3.0 enjoy
some ball wipes enjoy it go get them
enjoy it enjoy it
give me problems
do you think i say that out loud twice a
day to be honest with you oh okay this
is a good one
my mate is whipped right do you know
what i'm
yeah you know i think they mean um can
you even say that nowadays
he's possible can you even say that
nowadays i don't know if you're allowed
to say that anymore
if you're possibly you're not allowed to
say it good point
love the podcast have done since the
start a lot of people have been saying
that recently having seen the
retrospective video they're appreciating
good stuff now
uh when you've got potent vu john yeah
we don't talk about that my best mate is
so whipped it makes me cringe
we're in first year of uni and live in
the same flat
and so does his girlfriend oh that's a
mistake first of all
i'll point out some of the mistakes
you've made down the line here they were
talking before
christmas but it was clear she was more
interested than he was
so nothing stopped him from
sheeshing oh seshing right okay
basically
this guy has a best mate who is so
into this girl but he can't see that in
the long run that's a bad thing
first of all when you first you have uni
big piece of advice
don't go to uni whilst dating someone
don't start dating someone in the first
year of uni
it's extremely tempting you know first
of all
to go to uni dating someone you don't
want to let your high school sweetheart
go
sure we get it it's really hard you
don't want to be the bad guy you don't
need a person you're such a bullshitter
you're the biggest sentimental [__]
around
yeah but that's exactly what you were
did i go to university single though
yes that was purely by look if you would
have met her soon
giving it all up straight away yeah but
i mean she's a 10.
you know well then you have to disclaim
all that don't you right okay that's
what i'm saying but how many tens do you
know at the age of 17 or 18
right someone who can tick every box
that you want in your life and to be
honest at 17 or 18.
you don't even know what the boxes are
you don't even have five of the boxes in
there no it's 1718 you think
everything's ticked all the time right
exactly yeah
she just made me a cheese toasty tick
she can cook
you're like that's not cooking before
you go to uni don't hook up with someone
when you get to uni
try not to you know heavily get into it
with someone
because you're still finding yourself
give yourself the space to just be a
person
don't give yourself the space to let
your girlfriend move into the flat with
you do you know what i mean
i'd say continue that for at least four
years after uni
right no yeah i'm saying you know i'm
just saying until you're about 23
24 try not to you know really like
you know i think if you can be single
till you're 25 that's ideal
at least yeah yeah i actually agree with
that yeah
or yeah 20 24 25 is probably about the
time when you start going
okay everyone's bones are fully formed
now i can see what you're gonna look
like for the rest of your life you can
sort of begin to work it out you know
at 21 everyone's beautiful at 21 we've
all got something going for us which is
why the youtubers really struggle
because they come through at 17 or 18
they look fresh for a few years
you know we started when we were done i
do like the fact that we've actually
aged up better
whereas you can you can see some some of
the guys
i don't want to name names not going so
good no yeah yeah
and then it's sort of just looking like
you're just like an
older young-faced weird guy right you
know what i mean there's no need to be
so aggressive to harry but he does have
that look
harry i'm not talking about her all
right okay no nor am i
no hmm
scars and body confidence uh it's
actually
i think it might be a girl but the name
is it's tricky on okay yeah no it is a
girl
love the podcast and congrats on the
congrats on the beats deal it genuinely
says that good luck
do scars put men off a girl i'm very
insecure about a huge scar
across my stomach from a liver
transplant due to having
liver cancer when i was younger didn't
know i was going to take this turn i'm
sorry
i can't imagine ever being able to take
my top off and receive a reaction
or even if someone was to question it
i just want an honest opinion on how a
scar is perceived
no you're right leave all your clothes
on because everyone else has got a
perfect body
and ultimately we're only looking for
people with perfect bodies thank you
and ultimately i have when i take my
t-shirt off there's nothing
on me it's put it's i look like a ken
doll up until this massive penis
so it's the same advice from your brand
your body's perfect under that isn't it
i personally just think i understand why
where she's coming from especially women
like i think people don't understand
this
people talk about beauty standards
there's there's there's a lot of beauty
standards put on men
right yeah we we talked to ben the owner
of jim shock about you know
body positivity for men as well like
even men now are feeling like
[__] can i have this can i have that you
know what i mean i've got some
stretch marks and bloody scars so do i
you know but i get it like i think women
especially feel under a lot of pressure
and
when a woman has a scar um
in a spot like that it can be daunting
as [__] because she's just like
oh my god what is the reaction gonna be
like
and i think look
finding a nice guy for a start is is a
winner because the guy
is probably just going to be absolutely
fine about it but also
the lads i know personally wouldn't be
bothered by that so for example one of
my mates once
dated a girl who had a stoma she was
from estonia sorry a stoma
is not what they call them he had an
absolute stormer and he managed to pull
her
no it's a bag for you you know when
you've got
a oh bag yeah yeah and when you take
those off it's something called the
storm
oh right where basically it just touches
yeah and
like at no point was he ever like
commenting on that to me
or oh it's weird or anything that would
be very strange if he had
no but but the point i'm making is
women like this girl in question is
probably worried that men would go
oh and then she had this horrible like
at no point was anything ever mentioned
about something like that which you know
i can imagine for
the girl would have been quite a
daunting thing because of the nature of
what
comes out of there and whatever else you
know that it's a tricky situation for a
woman to deal with on a day-to-day basis
and you know if you want to get down and
and dirty so to speak
it's probably a bit of a of a of a
situation that she has to contend with
but especially if it's quite those tend
to be quite visible things of course
yeah but it wasn't a big deal no that is
the point is like because he cared about
her
yeah and that's the thing is when
someone does care about you
a scar will be no big deal i mean at all
like let's also be straight up here like
you are you're a [__] badass
like you got a liver transplant to
overcome liver cancer and you are i mean
i'm hoping you've kind of made it out
the other side of that now which is why
you're thinking of getting a girlfriend
or a boyfriend or whoever you want to
you know
have sex with or whatever like that's
actually a pretty cool story to be able
to tell someone i know it's
obviously it's traumatic in a way but
it's also like a life experience where
not many people have been through that
not many people have made it through
that and
the respect level that i have for people
who have made it through cancer is
incredible
but also just to be able to sit opposite
someone and say yes i've got a scar here
but that comes from this
then when someone's in the bed maybe
that's that's a solution so what i was
going to suggest is
bring it up long before you're taking
your clothes off and
and let and be aware of it like let the
guy be aware of it so
otherwise it sort of goes like this you
take it off and you go by the way there
was this
uh liver cancer thing and i had the uh
transplant and that's that's why and
they sort of go
sorry i've what and yeah
dress it at dinner i would say early-ish
on
if if you decide you like the person let
them know
and if you're worried about their
reaction or you're worried about what
they're going to think
i don't know what position it is but
like you could even
on your phone show a picture of it or
something and just say it's smart this
is what it looks like you know
and just so that it's done it's all very
done with it scars are kind of who you
are in a little bit of a way though do
you know what i mean
like scars are life experience well
they're a bit like tight as well right
do you know what i mean
i i've got scholars from [__] i've
broke this and i've had bar fights and
stuff
and um it ain't a big deal though do you
know me
and i get for a guy it's different but
not really like you know if
if i was with a girl about a scar i i
really wouldn't give a [__]
like at all and in many ways like you
know when you really fall in love with
someone then you fall in love with their
body
so you kind of just those things kind of
come with them
they're like part of the package i mean
it literally is part of who they are and
and i think yeah like i've
i've never i've never even heard a guy
mention oh i was
you know men are very they're
straightforward creatures to be honest
like um
you know if you look good and you smell
good
men are not really going to care about
the odd little mark like that and even
if it's a big score no one gives a [__]
and actually we're a lot more
understanding i'd imagine than a lot of
people i think i think
i do think men are typecast as like you
know and i get i'm probably part of the
problem like like i was talking about
earlier like you know
but like you can still have a big bomb
and a massive scar
i mean literally an ass croc is right
yeah it is just one long sort of split
in the body really isn't it
but but what i mean is like i think men
are far more
chill and understanding about stuff like
that um don't get me wrong before
everyone
hammers us in the comments i'm sure
there's the odd [__] but generally
speaking
it's fine i guess that's her fear as she
interacts with the [__] and in that
scenario
you have to know it's not you and you
also have to if you're worried about it
and you are going to be
gutted if anyone says something wrong
choose wisely
yeah because actually you should be
choosing wisely who you go to bed with
anyway
because you know there's a lot of [__]
out there do you know what i'm saying
um anyway the point moving on
uh this is quite a good one um this
one's from a guy
and he says how to get back into good
workout routine
after depression so i guess this could
be an interesting one
um before i get started uh
on my problem i just want to give the
typical how much your channel okay blah
blah blah
you guys blah blah blah blah blah blah
okay
uh anyway enough of that thanks i need
to talk about the gym i'm 24 years old
five foot nine
okay so about average height right is
five foot nine average height or
a boat about that uh and fifteen and a
half stone okay so you're quite uh
a heavy guy for five nine that is that's
a lot of muscle
my mother passed away of cancer in 2019
and since then it's been hard
for me to cope with her death i don't
drink
smoke or do drugs so my coping method is
eating
i can cook but whatever a takeaway is
there i eat it to comfort me
i've tried going to the gym and try to
lose weight but never
quite get that far long story short how
do you find the motivation to get over
depression and eating
and get into the dietary gym exercise
recommendation site i don't know if i'm
the perfect guy to give advice on the
eating
right because i sell something else you
are good at
you have become better at um like
managing your diet and you are
you know i you've expanded uh your
menu of what you would eat because when
you first came to london we did just go
to shake shack every week whereas now
you're a bit more like
oh i might have this with a salad like a
steak and this or
you know you like italian i try and
replace things so like if i'm if i'm
hungry
i'll rather than having like i got like
protein shakes and protein biscuits and
stuff so i'm like
this is sort of convincing my head i'm
having a biscuit
right you know what i mean it's a
protein biscuit taste like by the way
they're like cookies yeah they're like
but they're made from oats and stuff and
they've got a little bit of a chocolate
taste but
it's not like proper but you know it's
enough to and
make you feel full and stuff like that
makes me miss that place under 500
that we used to have around so good we
found this restaurant on delivery we
don't care about the problem so much but
uh no like we found this place on
delivery and genuinely
it was so good like every meal you got
from there was really really good but it
gave me the idea of like
how easy it is to find healthy meals
which also tastes good well it isn't
easy because now that place is gone
because of lockdown so
um yeah let's so
part of the problem is he's
still grieving and i think if he hasn't
he needs to talk to someone about
his mother it doesn't have to be a
counselor i would heavily recommend
um once a week find someone who knew her
if if possible okay and talk about some
memories just go over
half an hour have a couple talk about
memories
that that'll help with the grieving um
it's about doing little bits at a time
as well so like with the training
part of the problem is when you're
depressed you don't want to do anything
it's about just doing little bits to
start with like
if if you think yourself all right i'm
going to get my running trainers on or
whatever
i really can't be [__] asked to do
anything today
just say 10 minutes what's 10 minutes
nothing 10 minutes just go out even if
you don't run for the 10 minutes
run until you're tired and walk when you
can be asked to run again run again
yeah and then check your watch when
you've done 10 minutes and go back and
say
i achieved 10 minutes i did it then
up the time whenever you can be asked
and the next day you might have more
motivation
so you say i'm going to do 20 minutes of
that to do that same [__]
running and walking running and walking
and it can be baby steps it could be 15
minutes
it could be 12. set yourself a minimum
and go i have to do that 10 minutes
yeah so the next day when you're sitting
there feeling like [__] in your in your
depression's worse again
go but i'm going to do the 10 minutes
because i promised myself
i'll do the 10 minutes and then do the
10 minutes and if you've got a minimum
on your worst day that you know you'll
do
what you find is them endorphins start
happening a little bit more and a little
bit more
and the ability to push on and there'll
be a point where you think i've got to
do that minimum 10 minutes
and you'll feel rock bottom but you'll
get to that 10 minutes one day and
you'll go you know what [__] it
i'm going to do half an hour yeah and
you'll push yourself off an hour and
afterwards you think
i [__] did half an hour do you know
what i mean is that what you've done and
to get running and
the fitness grows and grows and grows
and the confidence grows and
and the positivity grows you need
patience for that that that requires
some patience does
you do but true jody is telling you
you have to do this mate so now you have
to do it and then you have to tell us
later on
how you got on so do that i do like that
um and i've done this myself this is
exactly how i've started running again
and it works it literally works so
you know when i started i was running
slow i was walking slower
and i was only doing 10 minutes now i'm
doing half an hour
comfortably now i can do an hour if i
want you know what i mean and then you
build it up because i had my minimum
and then there'll be days you know where
you know your body is tired or whatever
but you just have to have that minimum
and go i will do that 10 minutes
anyway hope that helps good advice and
um
in regards to eating healthy it's tricky
but yeah
yeah i think i let's not try and my
advice would be sort the diet last
if you love your food trying to eat
healthy as well as tackle the the death
of his mother and
exercise and then and then do all three
it's going to be too much
do the other two first when you feel
like your exercise is good
and and you and you're feeling better
about losing your mom which is hard
enough for anyone
then do the diet after that it's tricky
isn't it because if you take on all
three
you might just collapse early and then
and then you'll be back to square one
that's what happened with me
yeah you did take on quite a lot once
yeah i [__] it up the plates
uh i've got a good one here it's advice
on destroying my fuckboy mentality
please help this one's called call me
joe and it feels like the last five
years of my life though right
yeah yeah well destroyed they are i'm a
third year uni student studying maths
and i thought of commitment to one girl
and sorry the thought of commitment
to one girl makes me feel sick it all
started my first year when i was
uh when i was living in my humble abode
i was like
really um and i would trek
up to the north midlands where i began
my journey into further education
wow this guy's a bit of a writer but
some of his english isn't very good i
can say what you're doing mathsmate
uh i don't know i didn't know what to
expect in my first year but boy oh boy
was i in for a treat
this is a real one fresher's week was
amazing
beers boys [__] nightclubs that only
got bigger and bigger and bigger
and i love big tits and big ass and i
was hanging around with lots of big tits
and big asses in very skimpy dresses
good boy wow good luck um obviously your
boy was smashing through birds
quicker than jake paul knocked out ben
askren oh [__] son
good reference for geordi though he puts
in brackets i genuinely thought life
cannot get any better than this i hadn't
can he don't say smashing through birds
okay that's a dead giveaway that you're
a terrible show
right that's uh first of all dead
giveaway that you're a terrible shack
secondly
it's a an alarm in a woman's head that
you're a [__] boy
yeah yeah i mean he knows it himself but
i'm just saying like even to me
when you say i'm smashing birds i go you
[__]
yeah they're they're not having a good
time these girls are so disappointed
yeah they're disappointed but he's going
that was great
they're walking away in the morning
going and that is the last time i'll be
seeing you
well it's interesting because there's a
whole of the next year i was [__] and
chucking every bird i could
well they're chucking him by any chance
that's what that's what i'm thinking and
i just i'll never call her again she's
like yeah no [__] bro i've changed my
number she's also genuinely like that's
lucky
uh i genuinely couldn't stop thinking
about sex i think this guy's another
problem he then attaches a photo of him
where he has abs and
uh quite uh prominent pectoralis can you
can you show me and we'll just go on the
wide so that the
yeah no one could say these
right so he loves himself there yeah
clearly he's that kind of guy
fair player though you gotta have
confidence so uh you know i rate the
confidence if nothing else
near the end of my second year i met
this girl that was my
ideal type c below okay
he's really like gone into detail you
know what it is i [__] rate the story
telling if not else
she's very pretty girl no we're going to
need a close-up okay i'll ball for them
to be honest with you i want to see if
he's punching or not
you see what i'm saying right uh very
pretty
just just to verify on behalf of the boy
facially
she she's a very pretty girl yeah he's
done very well for himself
he's done very well and she's definitely
facially prettier than he is
uh because that fringe doesn't do you
any favors
i'm joking it's a joke relaxing yeah
near the end of my second year i met
this girl that was my ideal type bracket
c below we've seen below
we rate below and i ended up going out
with her for like 10 months but over
that period of time i began to realize
that the first three months of the
relationship was way better than
anything after
the honeymoon yeah yeah welcome to
reality
reality i think every man and his dog
feels that way
you know when when things start off with
a girl oh admit what
she can't suck your dick enough right
right
when when when things are at the start
like uh
it is beautiful so he then says and uh
this is but also terrible um it started
great
but ended bad with me eventually dumping
her i felt like she just piled all her
problems onto me
and then expected me to make her feel
better without giving a [__] about how i
felt can i just say a minute
that's relationship right i'm sorry
i'm sorry uh generally speaking
and and and look there's some there's
some good girls
there's some very good girls out there
but sometimes
you become some sort of [__] weird
diary right where
they're right on your [__] you know
in your head
here is my problem as if your job is to
[__] solve it
and a lot of people check out the hook
well my dj revolves it a lot of people
have problems like this where they don't
realize how negative they can be and
they just
project project and very often their
partner will sort of go
yeah because they think that's how a
relationship but what you you know you
start off trying to be the white knight
in shining armor
and you thought okay well i'll try and
help you with this i'll try and help you
but you get to a point as a man where
you know and look again some of you
women out there
are lovely lovely caring people some of
you are some whiny console
and i i just want to be honest and
it gets to a point as a man where you go
i ain't a [__] therapist bro sure
don't [__]
like you need to give them an hourly
rate like i can
you know there's there's understanding
and then there's a point where it goes
beyond that and you go
you are affecting my mental health
because all you're doing is [__]
complaining
that can happen both ways brian's not
just saying that's a woman absolutely
yeah
absolutely i'm i'm coming to the right
i'm coming at this
from a man's point of view talking about
my experiences with women
some have been great some haven't been
so great but the point i'm making about
people
is some people are radiators some people
are drains the radiators will warm up
your [__] life the drains will suck
the [__] life out of it try and find
a radiator but those people tend to be
able to take some things out and add
something
no but look i find radiators people who
people who add and warm up your life and
make it better because
this girl is a classic case
and i'm not having a go there because
she's probably lovely deep down
of someone who is not content within her
own self
and is not even in a position to have a
relationship right
and there's plenty of people who go
their entire lives
you know without and we even had this
clip in the [__]
the beats video yeah you've got to be
the person who makes you happy
before you even start having a
relationship with someone else and you
agree with it heavily then as well
and it's true you know what i mean and
i've been a victim of it i've been
guilty of it rather of
of of trying to start something while i
was a [__]
mess right so i'm not just saying it's
just other people like
i've done this yeah i've done this
before because
sometimes you're a [__] show of a person
as i've quite obviously been at times
and you see someone you like and you're
like they make me happy
and before you know it you
you're you know bringing them down
because you're a [__] mess and you're
in a position
to to make them right happy either and
like so it can be both ways i'm
certainly not just pointing the finger
but
generally speaking i i think you need
like
people generally need a watch out for
that happening because it can
it can happen without you even realizing
like all of a sudden like this guy says
he was like
wait there the first three months were
great this this is [__]
like that ain't supposed to happen try
not to meet someone in them
the best thing i can say is try to meet
someone at the beginning of winter
because if you can make it through
winter together you can make it through
anything
it's no one's fault when that happens
but it
in an ideal world you'd be able to say
it with the significant other whether
you're a man or a woman
you need to sort of have have
therapy you need to do this you need to
do that but the problem is with some of
those people
they're completely unaware of the habit
they're in
and they tend to be the type of people
who do take their stuff out on other
people
and can lash out with other people and
it's a tricky one
you know the best thing you can kind of
do is is treat it like a bomb
and just sort of slowly back away so he
then says
uh however now i'm in my final year and
starting to look to the future
when life isn't all about plowing
through as many birds as i can so he's
come full circle good for him
um he thinks he has bit up yeah sure but
after finding
the one that's right for you which is
why i have my lawrence's commitment to
his relationship and his partner i
respect the love and loyalty they have
in their relationship
thanks um uh congrats on the child
thanks for that okay okay um
my problem is that every girl i meet yep
good
after i shag them i instantly want to
move on
i am worried that i won't ever be able
to commit to anyone because the
relationship
i mentioned previously opened my eyes to
how much of a chore
it is having a bird okay okay so
gotta love him you are you are a classic
lad and and and i've been one for a long
time
so my advice
would be and this is this is some crazy
advice this isn't great
crazy crazy get ready for it crazy
you're ready brace yourself stop
shagging
whoa okay i don't like that you need to
take a [__] break because the problem
is
he's rifling through these girls at such
a rapid speed
he can't tell which one's good which
one's
not made for him right which one to
appreciate
which one to take his time on which one
to give an actual chance to
they're all blending in they're just
[__] at this point and
that is unhealthy because what he
doesn't realize is
he ain't respecting them and he ain't
respecting him either
like here like all right you're getting
you're getting your nut right but
before you wake up and realize this is
going to happen
you're going to have lower self-esteem
because you're going to realize
you're just given the dick that any girl
and you're not treating yourself as like
anything that's worth working for either
right so
you're not in a life situation that's
ever going to result
in meeting a good person who you can
have a long-term thing with
because you're just shagging everything
that moves
so there is no hope for you you you
ain't got to pray
and you will know like if while you're
on this [__]
[__] go around it ain't gonna work you
know
so get off the [__] go around start
saying stop right now stop the [__] go
around
yeah all right and the guy's going the
guy's on the mic going round and round
and round it goes where's stop nobody
knows and you're like oh i just want to
get off
no like he he does and and what he needs
to do is remember that people
can be special like it ain't just
i need to [__] you it ain't just that
there is more to
people than that do you also think maybe
this guy because he's only seeing it as
sex is blinding himself to some of the
good things that he could see
because he's trying to get just straight
to the sex that's the point i'm making
it's like what is going to happen is
inevitably
and i've done this before you'll
masturbate a lot no no
he is going to look back and realize one
of those girls who he tries just uh
nah get out my bed he should have he
shouldn't have
yeah like i'm not saying it would have
worked out with that person
obviously for me um there was there was
a a couple of people
at least who i should have tried with
more respect that i regretted because i
was like you know maybe
maybe that could have went well maybe i
but i didn't give it a chance because i
was in that
[__] state of mind that this kid's in
where he's just trying to shag
everything horrible absolutely horrible
um
look i'm not saying don't [__] plenty of
people but
you've you've been doing this for a
while now at university as well so
you've had some good years you've made
your point
yeah now's the time to start dating
you've proved you're the man
calm the [__] down yeah and and and not
only that bro if you're
if you're rattling through girls the way
he says he is that isn't actually going
to get you the best sex either
right you'll have better sex if you are
dating a girl for a longer term
great advice yeah you hit this window
where
the understanding is just there you both
know what you like and you're about and
you're just like
this is really bro three he said three
months is when it went bad
three months should be when it starts
getting great apex yeah right three
months is when
you you know the early stuff is has been
in gone and that that the fun
and you're discovering each other yeah
that's the bit where you really start
confessing to each other let's try and
do this you're not as tentative anymore
yeah
do you like that you're sort of going
you like that yeah you know each other
better and therefore
the sex gets even better so yeah you
know he's kind of
ironically [__] himself out of even
better sex so
i think yeah the the problem is
everything's just blurred into one right
now and he needs to start a step back
and go
hold on which of these girls are a good
looking but b
and most importantly a good person and
you know funny smart good partner caring
yeah and enriching my life a little
little word advice go for
a i want sometimes
as men we can be um like dogs you know
we need
something to be exciting all the time
but don't
don't you know um what's the word go for
someone who's caring
and uh who watch the body because what
i'm saying is because he's an ego maniac
as as i was um when women praise him and
care about him and really like him
he'll think he's above them just the
word about you're not that makes you a
narcissist you're not yeah
no but he will he's a man as well and
you know he thinks he's the guy
so and and he has been he's he's killed
it well done but
you need to realize that one of these
girls who actually believes you are the
[__]
is gonna like be there for you and
actually rate you and support you
and you're actually not what you think
you are so if if you're lucky enough to
have someone who thinks you're that
great
don't just treat her like yeah and and
wait for a [__] girl to come along and
actually [__] with your head a bit
like appreciate that because that as a
man we
i've done that before like i've
undervalued someone who rated me highly
when really you want someone who really
thinks you're great and you can mistake
that for like yeah i'm so great i don't
even need you
don't that's that's good yeah do you
know what i mean
and what's happening right now is
there's probably a few of them treating
them nice and he's not
he's not saying it i like that it's good
advice
it's actually great advice do you do you
want to end there only because i feel
like you you've really done good advice
at the end there and i don't want to end
on a pizza not on uh
yeah you know when i like where we go
well yeah yeah i i hope people enjoyed
this old school podcast a bit of a catch
up with uh
you know uh us too it got a bit uh deep
sometimes as it always does
um thanks for sharing yeah but uh we
really appreciate the support lily it's
been [__] unbelievable
across the kickoff uh tj extra and
obviously the main channel on twitch
you know we're always doing something
cute you're a machine
a factory keep watching us many many
days a week we're a
content machine yeah sure it's good to
work with you
thanks for coming it's good to work with
you last
it's good great to work with you it's
good good to share the room
uh like the video don't forget the links
are in the description
subscribe thanks for watching and we
will see you
[Music]
later
you